all right people we are live on the
YouTube or we're at least live until the
stream crashes we shall see what happens
and I am sitting between the famous
Weinstein brothers
I've got Eric to my left I've got Bret
to my right in no order by the way did I
intro you or seat you the order in which
we were born
that's perfect sentence the order in
which you were born as you guys know I
believe that there is an idea revolution
happening in this country I think these
two a right at the center of it they
happen to be born from the same two
parents we're going to talk about that
and a lot more first off you guys
arrived together you took a car here
together you actually like each other as
brothers that's pretty good quite a bit
yeah quite a bit quite a bit we don't
see each other all that often but this
is the first time we've ever appeared
the same place like ever ever with all
the professional stuff that you guys
have done you in the math world you in
the biology well this is somehow the
first time you've done this this is the
first oh no I have no idea what happened
I guess I first should ask you the
family hair what's going on here we have
the other didn't you as the more temped
burger yes thank you haven't glad I'll
ask you what is going on in the in this
family with the hair holy-holy curly
well the hair is a is a is a bit of a
curse and the problem is that there are
a lot of people who who enjoy pointing
that out and I'm actually I'm not going
to bring this live until March but I'm
gonna institute a rule where it's fine
to make nasty comments about the hair as
long as they come with a helpful
suggestion mine is always on your
YouTube comments
yeah he's the managing director of teal
Capital why can you afford a decent
weave yeah well I love the fact that we
could talk for like two hours you
mentioned 87 theories or go way over my
head and 90% of the comments are about
your hair alright let's just do a little
history with stuff with you guys first
because obviously we're gonna talk about
so much more stuff here but obviously it
seems to me at least from the outside
your parents must have done
thing right that they got two brothers
who so care about ideas but are true
experts in their field of math and
biology and that care about doing what
what I see as what's right and and being
brave enough to constantly do that what
did they do that was right or where did
this this passion for education and all
of that come from older brother you
first oh boy well I mean I think that
the family history has a few ingredients
and not all of them are about the
nuclear family I think that we there
were four families that came out to
California we grew up not too far from
here and the they came out to make
mayonnaise it was the gelfand who
figured out how to make mayonnaise not
separate properly the Kern extermo
glands and the Reubens and the Reubens
were the weakest branch
families that buy no no we are Rubin
chicks yeah and so we were raised by
Harry and and Sophie Rubin as well as
our parents and Harry Rubin was a
chemist who couldn't finish college I
think there's a family history of
learning issues and there was a lot of
question about how to how to ground
one's idealism and rationality so that
you are fundamentally thinking with your
head feeling with your heart and that
the two of them remain connected and I
think that there was a lot of emphasis
on not taking shortcuts to a better
tomorrow and taking massive risks yeah
I'm glad you mentioned the head heart
thing because I think you're
particularly in that space these days
well you know it's tough because I think
that you know as we've been talking
about this group of people who's sort of
growing up outside of the standard
channels of communication you know and
made a joke about the intellectual dark
web and then it got repeated we sort of
ran with it but the only part of it that
was dark was that the media and the
institutions weren't you know we're sort
of making sure to avoid any reference to
this group of people as much as possible
and you know I think that you know this
intellectualism outside of the
mainstream was definitely a part of our
family growing up and I think that the
learning issues in some sense
disconnected us from standard
institutional structures and you know
one of the things I think we'll get to
hopefully today is that well people are
tuning in to this conversation that that
Bret and I have been having for a long
time there were a lot of previous rounds
where there just wasn't anyone to talk
to and there were a lot of different
issues that got brought up and I it
would be great to use this current
passion where you you may see it over
free speech perhaps I see a little bit
less so over that but it would be great
to talk about some of the previous
battles that we've fought that involve
things like drug testing or wealth
transfer by using the CPI as a closet
way of raising taxes and slashing
benefits so we've been at this a long
time and the great new thing I think is
is that there's so many new voices and
there's this channel to go around and to
disintermediate this very strong thing
that I call the gated institutional
narrative which we've never been able to
crack through so easily and now we have
channels where we can we can actually
get to the yeah well as I said to you
guys right before we started I mean I've
scribbled down a few things here but I
fully want you guys to take as much
control here as you see fit I mean he
teed you up on a couple things there but
just first just on the family stuff
growing up I mean we're in the house
like was just education and education
and education just constantly drilled
into you guys well I mean the funny
thing is the concept of education was
was quite prominent but as Eric points
out neither he nor I had a comfortable
experience in school they were different
uncomfortable experiences but both of
them were troubling for you for example
what does that mean oh I was actually I
think Eric figured out some mechanisms
for getting through school that were
more effective than what I did and in my
case I actually remember being in the
second grade and
my handwriting and spelling in
particular were so bad that I remember
somehow I remember school giving up on
me and declaring me off in some way and
I you know this is the adult me looking
back but I felt a choice
I can either submit to what it's
judgment of me is and I can try to
confront it or I can stop playing ball
and that's what I did
which caused my academic life to come
apart and really it didn't go back
together arguably ever although I did
find a home in graduate school but but
the process of walking away from the
formal education and then having our
grandmother died relatively early but
Harry our grandfather was a he was a
really interesting intellectual person
who had the unique characteristic of
taking children very seriously and it
doesn't mean he wasn't fun he wasn't in
it he was extremely fun but it meant
really if I think back on it you could
ask him any question any question if it
was a good question he would do his best
to answer it and he would let you know
at the point that you'd topped out what
he could address and that it was like
having a personal intellectual tutor and
you know that was that was one faster
that was particularly important maybe
especially for me but it sort of picked
up where school left off and because he
was an unusual mind in his own right I
think some of the stuff that Eric and I
picked up from him ended up being sort
of jumping off points to places that are
hard to get to through the standard a
standard model yeah I'm curious did
either one of you even now where you're
both obviously public people and and you
were sort of thrust into it just eight
months you know that what was it if it's
about yesterday right
did you ever anticipate that you'd be
someone that is talking about these
things publicly you know to me like you
had this is a very long piece of work
but now you end up sort of talking about
this stuff from a zillion different
angles well I I don't think either one
of us wanted to become a public figure
per se I think we wanted to do work and
we wanted the work to go into the world
and then it turned out that the the
opposition to the work like it's
important that this work never be heard
is a very different thing then it's
important that this work be heard and
that it be evaluated properly and if
it's found to be wanting discarded so I
think that we ended up spending a lot of
our energy just mystified as to hey I've
come up with this great new thing I've
got a new discovery I've got a new way
of seeing things why are people so angry
and hostile and that created a choice in
some in some sense where we had to give
up a certain amount of privacy and I you
know I still value our privacy like you
know I don't think either one of us
tweets pictures of our children or
something like that or even names them
and I think it's in some ways a little
bit uncomfortable oh yeah oh yeah
tremendously uncomfortable and the ideal
would be to have the ability to speak
into the public dialog in an important
way but not be recognizable so that you
could have your your anonymity and your
influence simultaneously but nonetheless
you're saying the Twitter avatar people
might be doing something a little wiser
than the three of us is that it these
they're maintaining their anonymity and
at least at some level getting in on the
conversation yes on the other hand I
think part of what is driving the sort
of surprised interest you know I feel
surprised interest in me and an eric is
the void of authenticity and so the very
fact of anything authentic it doesn't
matter if it lines up with the way you
think things are or not just a simple
fact that it's unpolluted by [ __ ] is
so powerful that it
it causes people who wouldn't otherwise
be interested in what you had to say to
listen so at some level I feel like
that's the trade is that we have given
up the anonymity part in exchange to
illustrate that this really is authentic
and that that that is driving a lot of
the interest yes I feel like our hands
are somewhat forced that it is
astounding all of the interesting and
important things that aren't simply not
being said mm-hmm in a world where you
know you go through these news cycles
and just repeats the same mind-numbing
perspective that doesn't really I mean
it can't be made some sense of upon
reflection I think you know just getting
back to your original question I think
our grandfather Harry Rubin in
particular refused to teach and in at
least in my case you know I remember he
gave me this guitar and he said all you
need to do is tune it you don't need to
play it and it was a very strange
instruction like why would you have a
guitar if you could only tune it and his
point really was
it'll be so frustrating to have a nice
guitar that is tuned that you don't know
how to play then he will figure out that
it's a mystery and that you do not need
a teacher and I remember going to UCLA
music library and xeroxing all of these
beautiful guitar pieces I could barely
read the notes on the page but it turned
out that you know this was a very
strange and interesting form of teaching
for two people who couldn't actually and
and I just I it really needs to be
emphasized you can think all you want
about privilege about maleness or
whiteness or this or that but if you
have a learning disability that is
conceived of by the educational system
it is almost impossible to lead a normal
life and so you either find some crazy
way of overcompensating and then you you
have an original perspective because the
system can't serve you or you sort of
accept that you are the problem
and I think neither of us accepted that
we were the problem and it's sort of a
radical overreaction to to the mismatch
in education so oh good well there's one
other thing I just want to add before we
move on from it which is
there's an important question about
birth order and where we end up birth
order is an interesting mystery because
if you imagine that where you fall on
the birth order causes you to lead a
very different life than you would have
if you had been born somewhere else in
it that almost sounds like a failure of
evolution to function because whatever
you should be doing optimally you should
do on the other hand you're born into a
world that is altered by the siblings
that were born ahead of you and so for
me
I think part of why I end up where I do
is that I was born into a world with
Eric in it and Eric was a very unusual
intellectual presence to be in your
natal home you know yeah I do say so you
know if you think about it
eric has a extreme talent for
fundamental thinking and when I say
fundamental I mean the most fundamental
levels of thinking that meant that the
niche in the home I was born into that
niche was full fundamental thinking
wasn't wearing was going to be at and so
it is I think totally fair to say that I
ended up as far away from the
fundamental as you could get right
biology is about complexity and
emergence and so in order to you know
maximize the chances of contributing
something that was not already taken
care of I went to the other end and I
got very fascinated with living systems
and it turns out that actually that pair
of toolkits is pretty useful together
Eric is much better at understanding my
toolkit he's quite good at evolutionary
thinking in a way that I will never be
good at mathematical thinking and so
anyway there is a a way in which I think
the the Williams sisters the tennis
players provide something of a model of
one of the aspects that was very unusual
in our house which was there was a kind
of and you've said it before on maybe on
your program about a kind of
intellectual arms race you know a
friendly sibling intellectual arms race
that resulted in us you know both upping
our
just to keep up with try but it was also
like a off-script in other words it was
like two twins speaking a language that
nobody else was speaking and you're
competing inside of this ring it's like
a system that nobody even knows that
this competition is going on and I think
you know bread is actually slightly
inaccurate in that what he did in
biology was to take this emergent system
and treat it as an as if fundamental
system and I think that's where so much
of his power comes from is is that he
treats evolute like most people think of
evolution as kind of bedrock and I think
Brett goes below that and says look
they're the critiques of evolution have
more to it than you imagined but the
solution isn't a religious solution it's
actually better more fundamental
theorizing about a layer that can
actually support that even though
there's no reason you should be able to
do fundamental thinking in such a high
level emergent layer so I feel like he
sort of copied the same behavior pattern
and I also think in terms of birth order
just to be entirely honest about it I
don't think Brett really became Brett
until I left the house like he was
almost mute he was very very shy I
wouldn't say anything and when I left
the house suddenly you know I'd been
pretty good in Speech and Debate
and Brett would just clean up from
public speaking in a level that I
couldn't and you know there's also this
aspect where you feel that as an older
sibling you are in part suppressing you
the younger sibling unintentionally so
that it's not mean-spirited it's just
something those things are already
occupied and so as soon as you leave the
house suddenly you have an as if Brett
became an as if older sibling or an only
child and I think that really catalyzed
the transformation all right so there's
a lot here so it seems to me that for me
personally my whole life has sort of led
up to this right I sort of mean this
actual moment because this is what I do
but I mean what is this thing that's
happening right now that we can all feel
the reason that you know all these new
people loved you that didn't know who
you were a year ago
or that you know two or three years ago
when you message me and you said can we
just jump on skype for a second I had no
idea who you were and I did a quick
google and I was like this guy's seems
bright let's talk and and everything
that is sort of flowered out of that but
it seems like there's something
happening right this moment that is way
bigger than certainly than three of us
sitting here
when did you start tracking it early
eighties the Reagan transition was very
violent very interesting and the
university system was the first place
that I was able to notice that the
institution's contained fundamental
structural laws that they'd been built
in a different time and they required
growth that could no longer be supplied
and so can you give me an example of
what that means sure so I think I
mentioned this before but I think
pre-war we educated about 8% of the
population at a post-secondary levels of
some kind of after high school training
and then we went to about 50% of the
population so that's a huge expansion in
a very brief period of time from 1945 to
about 1970 and the university system
couldn't keep growing you can't have a
professor leaving you know fifteen PhDs
who all become professors who leave
fifteen PhD so that structure works as
long as the system is growing and as
soon as it hits steady-state then you go
from saying one professor should leave
fifteen students to one professor should
leave one student over a career well
that doesn't work because you need the
students to do work under the professor
same thing for lawyers you know and then
partners and associate same thing for
doctors you know maybe an intern you
need growth to have these structures so
then almost all of these institutions
stopped growing in this particular way
and then they had to have a story to try
to attract people in to pay in and it
became akin to Ponzi schemes and that's
why during this period of time you know
I wrote this this essay called anthropic
capitalism in the new
economy and the whole idea of the essay
was that we had kept these institutions
alive
by trying to figure every gimmick known
to man so offshoring downsizing
securitization playing with you know GDP
and CPI dials all of these sorts of
games were used to try to squeeze a
little bit more as if growth out of the
system so that nobody would have to
confront the fact that the whole thing
had become in some sense pathological
and my belief is is that with the end of
the baby boomer bubble if you will which
is a very long-lived bubble it's not
like a short you know bitcoin style
bubble what you have is a situation in
which the narrative is unsustainable by
2008 this narrative about deregulation
and the Great Moderation couldn't be
sustained and Lehman Brothers went down
an AIG was at risk of exploding in the
world financial system might have
collapsed and during the period that
followed it there was no ability to
create really strong new narratives and
the old narratives no longer work and so
what you're seeing is a little bit that
the institutions treat us almost like an
infection but their immune system is
weakened and so even though maybe
YouTube isn't thrilled with us on its
platform and Twitter may not be thrilled
and maybe the intelligence community is
worried about things getting incoherent
and media it doesn't like the
competition and sense making so far they
haven't really tried very hard to stop
us although I think that that can that
can change and these new ideas are
really just the ideas that we're being
suppressed so for example you know at
some point we will talk I'd like to talk
about why Brett should have become
famous
rather than evergreen making him famous
so I would have thought it would have
been his discovery that the laboratory
animals used for drug testing and other
purposes have extraordinarily long
telomeres on the end of their chromosome
which may make them very bad test
animals for drug for drug testing
because they have the capacity
to repair against the toxicity of a drug
and those animals will die of cancer but
that whole episode where Brett predicted
from first principles that the
laboratory animals would have wildly
elongated telomeres allowing for you
know radical histological repair of the
tissue there's no trace of that story in
the world there almost no trace of that
story so is that the sort of catch-22 of
your situation there you were you know
doing some great work and by every
account of every student that I've seen
right about you thought you were a great
teacher and and everything that Eric
just said and then what put you on the
map was something that was so backwards
in nature yet is so directly related to
all of these cystic these systems
crashing you were just one of the
symptoms of it actually yeah I saw I
stumbled into a realm where the system
had gotten feeble was lying to itself
just because I was intellectually
interested in a question that took me
there and you know the world of of
gerontology was polluted by the fact
that there's money to be made if you can
address the questions of Aging so that's
not why I was there but the point is the
lies they were telling themselves were
more pernicious than the ones that get
told over an evolution space and it it
was fascinating mean it was a trial by
fire I learned a ton about the way the
world actually functions from that and
the fact that it to this day
shows no public sign of having been
addressed is it is one of the the
artifacts of my trajectory realize that
multiple times I mean this is the crazy
thing is like the 5th 6th 7th time we've
been at this rodeo and we know we'll be
there again I mean Lindsey Shepherd you
know just a couple of months ago no
these are all in you that's the that's
one pattern and this is really
interesting which is you have you put a
ton of pressure on a large group of
people to salute some flag that
shouldn't be saluted mm-hm
and most people make the calculation do
I really want to screw up my life just
over whether or not I salute a flag
whether that's maybe it's diversity or
multiculturalism or something that
sounds pretty good and has a lot of good
stuff in it and then you've got like one
person
stand up and said say you cannot compel
me and this is how we found bread it's
how we found Jordan Peterson so he found
Lindsey Shepherd and in all cases the
commonality seems to be that the person
who doesn't salute the flag usually has
a very deep reason it's not just that
it's wrong it's that they've got an
entire worldview so what is the least
interesting interesting thing about
Jordan Peterson that he won't use
compelled pronouns and I'm sure you'll
agree use them as a courtesy it's right
kind of is you found out with Ben
Shapiro yes he absolutely worried and so
the whole idea is isn't it interesting
that the only people willing to screw up
their entire lives over these things are
people who the crowd will find it's like
a truffle hound you want to find the
really interesting professor at some not
so interesting field or a department or
an out-of-the-way university you just
have a compelled everybody's gonna sing
the following anthem every morning at
8:00 a.m. and the person who says no
that person's research which is totally
unrelated to singing the anthem at 8:00
a.m. you know wearing yellow or whatever
thing you're asking that person to do
that person is most likely to be the
person who is doing groundbreaking
research in an area that you would never
know and that's why I forward you all
these emails that I get from musicians
that are struggling with this that are
having the system collapse on them
because they might be a white
heterosexual choreographer or just
everyone that's a little bit different
in the system so if he was tracking this
thing since Reagan in the 80s you as the
first time I saw you on television you
said to Tucker I what did you say what
was it I'm deeply deeply progressing yes
okay all my bells went off what's wrong
with this guy you've also become a
master of Twitter in snark which is
really nice because your revolution has
been very quick on that regard but I
think that's what happened is that now
what happened not exactly okay so I was
I would had 400 Twitter followers in May
of last year so Twitter was not an
interesting place for me because most
people never I couldn't speak to anybody
yeah
what happened is that in May of last
year suddenly things became extremely
perilous for me and my the tool that I
had used in the classroom to great
effect
which was you humor to teach I mean in
fact if I think if I'm ungenerous with
myself a lot of what I did in the
classroom was in good humor troll my
students to force them to learn in order
to escape the little traps I set for
them and so anyway I feel like for the
last seven months or no over the last
eight months my sense of humor has been
suspended because it is so dangerous to
speak into this public void and you know
the dangers it's so dangerous but it's
back now I mean ice right that's
something you on Twitter now and it's
like you've become a master some part of
me has whether it's right or not has
begun to feel safe enough to return to
my sort of more complete persona and
that's showing up on Twitter eyes so
okay so he's tracking this thing from
the 80s you you're at us at a school
that is thought of as one of the the
most left or progressive schools you're
in the biology department which is
pretty much there's no biology you're so
progressive there no Department oh there
aren't even right there departments but
that this is your field of study at
least right there's no tenure there's
some other thing but snap book besides
down here but when did you sort of
realize wow this I mean you might it
couldn't have been the day that you sent
the email oh no a little bono that right
no this has been a long a long road and
I mean maybe the way to do this is to go
back a little bit to Eric's point about
the fact that these people who get
confronted and who stand their ground
over these points are always there for
some deeper reason and Eric points to
they have a relatively complete model
that they've built themselves so how do
you find those people well you start
saying wrong stuff and forcing people to
salute that flag and they people who
have built their own model of how the
world works won't do it because they
can't write you that are not built for
it yeah so I found my way there you know
I got interested in evolutionary biology
I found some people who are willing to
take me seriously as a freshman at the
University of Pennsylvania I realized I
had a talent for it and then I got to
the University of California Santa Cruz
where Bob Trivers was teaching and Bob
Trivers is one of the the great living
evolutionary biologist one of the great
evolutionary biologists of the 20th
century so we were just fortunate to
land in his milieu but anyway that was
sort of the evolutionary red pill like
this was somebody who was thinking at
the frontier of the field and he had
been part of the sociobiological
movement which tried to understand human
beings with the same tools that we could
understand a platypus and that was a
very controversial endeavor and in fact
it explains a kind of internal paradox
of the left which is that the left on
the one hand wants to be a champion of
evolution and Darwinism and on the other
hand the left is deeply uncomfortable
with the implications that Darwinism
might have for people and so the socio
biologists were trying to figure out how
to map Darwinism onto people and they
did a poor job because actually they
didn't have all the tools necessary to
do it but I got a glimpse of that in the
early 90s working with with trevor's and
I started and I didn't realize it was
what I was doing but I started building
up the kit of concepts and tools and
lenses that allow you to properly map
Darwinism onto people and so that thing
was something I was building and then
when I started teaching at Evergreen I
just simply turned it into the the
context of my classroom I taught them
the model that I had architected and
they pushed me around and the model got
better and so the recognition that the
story of human beings is actually an
evolutionary story and the sense that we
all have that the evolutionary part of
of humans is a quadrant of what we are
is just so wrong that it results in you
spotting these wrongheaded movements and
things like that and you know it's
definitely my recognition of where we
were and what it meant came over time I
think it wasn't as quick as as for Eric
at the point that occupy happened which
actually I participated in the quality
of the conversation inside of occupy was
so disappointing with respect
to what you would need to fix in order
to make civilization work that it kind
of woke me up that there was no adjacent
solution to the problems we were dealing
with that one had to think farther
afield in order to even begin to address
is it fair to say that I I've been
warning you about Olympia and evergreen
and occupy that in essence in order to
be in order to carry progressivism
properly in its best sense you actually
have to start from scratch almost
because the main branch of progressivism
is the most dangerous branch of thinking
currently found in the political
spectrum and the branch that I think you
and I how would you define that branch
well it's one that begins from a
substrate of thinking about oppression
which is not a fundamental language you
cannot make a cosmology or an
epistemology out of oppression and
resistance it just it leads to madness
the most difficult thing is to take the
burden of evolutionary thinking and the
theory of natural and sexual selection
and to realize that that is your tool
kit and from that tool kit you must
build something that doesn't look like
evolution has always looked before
because we're now on too crowded of a
planet and the toys we've been able to
produce from science are too powerful I
think Brett has called this wisely the
hard problem the really hard problem in
evolutionary theory which is you can't
continue to dance with the one that
brought you yeah because evolution gets
you here and it almost certainly will
end in a self-extinguishing event if you
keep playing the evolutionary game and
there is no thought and this is you know
I think that this is a bread is the best
person carrying this forward there is no
proof that there is a way to use
evolutionary building blocks to avoid
the evolutionary fate of having you know
unlock the twin nuclei of cell and atom
they're just too powerful as tools and
so this is why I think both of us come
down on the left even though we we now
travel in a world that often leans right
because the right is correct
about the left generally being in denial
like trying to wish yourself into a
better world where you know you want
sexual equality but you're not willing
to pay attention to what sex and gender
actually are you don't have any idea
what sexuality means because you're just
thinking about it in humans and you're
not studying it in a million different
species okay so you can't wish yourself
into a better tomorrow because that you
you will create you will try to create
utopia and both of us are strong anti
utopians that utopia always leads in
this topia obvious you go for it but we
also don't have any choice but we have
to get off this treadmill because as as
the tools get more and more powerful
it's very clear that if we continue to
run the evolutionary program there is no
guarantee that that we emerge from this
did you ever expect that it was gonna be
this political because it seemed like if
you look at just the things that I hear
you're talking about all the time
they're not necessarily political in
nature but everything now is political
they've been politicized but I would say
I mean there's a conversation coming and
I have the sense that those of so first
of all I I will say the last time I was
on your program the only time I was on
before I remember you asking me what I
thought of the left and I quipped what
left I haven't seen him and who knows
how long yeah that turns out not to have
been right they exist I mean yes I
hadn't seen them but one of the funny
things about my trajectory is that
having been you know the experience was
very much like being ejected from the
left yeah and I gotta ejected from the
left and a lot of people on the right
embraced me which was weird and then
even weirder was the discovery of all
the other people who had been ejected
from the left and so the point is this
is sort of a cryptic left you're talking
right exactly well and so so the point
is the discovery that there are a lot of
people who you might if you just looked
them up online you would come to the
wrong conclusion about where their
sympathies lay that that's interesting
and I think the conversation
between those of us who have been you
know catapulted out and those of us who
have landed on the right is going to
involve the recognition that in fact we
are all suffering from a kind of
political PTSD uh-huh and that in fact
many people who are on the right are
there because they've been traumatized
by really low quality dangerous leftist
thinking but that the that does not make
their right of center position natural
I'm not saying there are no natural
positions over there but many people who
are there are there because they have
run from things that they have heard on
the left and once we give up on the idea
that anybody on the map today has the
answer with respect to the policies that
we are supposed to embrace once we say
actually everybody's policies are a
failure if we were to enact the
libertarian program it would fail for
game theoretic reasons if we were to
enact the socialist program it would
fail for game theory same thing right so
the point is okay fresh sheet of paper
with respect to policy now there's a lot
for us to talk about starting from
values and there are a lot of people who
if you ask them to list their values
apart from policy would fall out on the
left so Wow is it an interesting moment
that that conversation may be about to
get started
to be in a position to actually
influence it I must say is pretty
exciting it's also one of the just no go
ahead
you know you said something which I
think can be misheard and since you've
had the experience coming off of The
Young Turks
it's worth saying the centre-right is in
some sense the blankest part of an on
blank canvas and so the whole purpose of
introducing the think position concept
was to analogize the left with Spain in
the center-right with Turkey and the
expulsion of the Jews and the idea being
that what you know like one of the
things that I always want to come to
your rescue about and also push you a
little bit on is is that there's this
army of Twitter trolls that say well why
won't ruin criticize the right and I
we've just never gone and done it in
part the point is if your heart is
largely in
making a better world and trying to be
realistic about it but recognizing that
we have to change them some things and
then you get kicked out of your home the
last thing you want to do is start
criticizing the people who took you in
during a really dangerous period and so
in part I think you give the right a
little bit of a pass and I think more
than I'm comfortable with yeah because
you also have the twin problem of
wanting to be decent to the the fact
that the people who have embraced I mean
you know I've always struggled with
Tucker Carlson last time I checked I'm
one of a hundred people that he's
following on Twitter and you know he
stepped up at a moment when other people
would not and so you know it's this very
violent shift in in in thinking that's
just not comfortable but the canvas is
blank enough that we can leave the sword
in the stone rather than saying the
answer is capitalism no the answer is
libertarianism no the answer is ending
oppression you can say we don't actually
have the answer we don't know and it's
very important that the people who are
certain be silent because they are not
the important people at this moment and
that's basically everyone on cable news
and everyone so well they all have their
like we know and they'll talk to you
about it I remember when I did the
macneil/lehrer Newshour they said look
Eric you have to be either for or
against immigration and I said why and
they said well if you're for it we'll
get a guy who's against it and if you're
against it we'll get a guy who's for it
but you can't be both for and against it
and they couldn't use anything from an
hour-and-a-half interview they did with
me because I needed to be a widget in
order to fit the pre-assigned format
that's this is where I started learning
about fake news and why our world is
constructed because you construct the
program before you meet the people and
so once you have the template you have
to shoehorn everybody into the template
to produce that very consistent product
think about you know if you buy salami
that's a lot of different individual
pigs but it all tastes like salami its
uniform eyes and that's what we're
dealing with and the our group is
discussing these issues is anything but
uniform it everybody's split
you know just exploring this ben shapiro
acting as the atheist that turns out to
be you know really quite quite quite
correct and you know the the fact that
Jordan and Ben both are up for using
sensitive pronouns but they were just
hiding that for some reason you know
this is a really rich Aryan that
richness is sort of an asthma to the
Machine that just needs a dependable
product and is going to grind us in to
some I don't know some uniform soil and
green to be to be distributed to the to
the world yeah well I'm sure there's
some mathematical or biological answer
even to what you're saying about me
right there which we've discussed
privately many times so I'm more than
happy to discuss it publicly as well you
know it's funny when I've sat down its
first off I think your basic premise is
actually correct as I've said to you
privately but when I've sat down with
all of these supposed scary
right-wingers so I have Shapiro and
Prager and gutfeld and who have gone
back and whoever has maybe they have
actually no problem publicly and
privately having disagreements with me
yeah no problem we don't slander each
other we don't slur each other we don't
hate each other we don't unleash mobs on
each other so yes I actually feel very
comfortable with them even though we
have certain political disagreements now
where I don't get a bat on the other
side I don't think you get it on the
other what I have this crazy thing where
I'm always asked why are you hanging
around with Rubin
you know because fundamentally you know
he's really right-wing and he refuses to
quit and you get why don't you have
left-leaning people on your show and so
that it's like are you are you aware
that you're talking to both of us were
able to compare notes but the irony is
that both of you by default of your
upbringing and everything else I think
would have you certainly were on the
left for basically your whole adult life
yes and I think basically you were -
it's a little I don't even know where to
put you anymore but that shows how the
map just means nothing anymore it just
doesn't mean anything what means
something is that little play that
little place you're talking about on the
canvas now and that place at the moment
happens to be center-right I think yeah
I mean is the thing that I so I'm
raising my children at least my son on
these old Tom Lehrer records
and Tom Lehrer was this incredible
pianist and he wrote naughty dirty
little songs you know way back in the
1950s that were incredibly clever and
witty and talked about politics and if
you if you play them today you know I
think about Barney I love you you love
me and then you have Tom Laird saying I
hold your hand in mine and it's a
severed hand you know it's just he was
making fun and joking about our hatred
for each other across ethnic lines about
sexual misbehavior and you know we grew
up in a house in which this was normal
and it produced a kind of
immunologically sophisticated rather
than an immunologically naive
perspective where we've we've created
this very safe world for children now
and I think our world was not safe and
you know I think it's very important to
look at what the effects of that if you
watched Vietnam on television during the
60s and early 70s as I did the images
that are were beamed into every living
room look like no images that were
beamed in from the Iraq war or even the
you know the collapse of the the Twin
Towers so you have a very different
world in a very different situation that
I think we grew up in and what you and I
find when we're told either you know
don't do Rubin show or why don't you
have left wingers on is that the left is
behaving in some sense like a cult a
cult is always wondering did you talk to
anyone outside well if you talk to
somebody outside then you might have
ideas come in that disconfirm what the
cult has been telling you and so the
fact that you and I always want to talk
and I'll talk I'll talk to a convicted
killer I'll talk to somebody with
horrible views because I you know if I
even if I just want to protect myself
against that person I want to understand
how they think how can you not watch if
you think Fox News is the enemy why
wouldn't you listen to the enemy's
broadcast hmm right and so this idea of
revulsion I cannot possibly even bear
two seconds of that voice
or that idea or that person is a tell
and it's a tell that the person is
trying to say don't worry I haven't
spoken to anyone outside of our cult
yeah these these rules that are
established are tactical and they are
rationalized as if they were about some
sort of a sophisticated conclusion but
they simply aren't and so you know I'm
not sure this is the right analogy I
don't want to trivialize it this way but
I almost feel like the left has revived
the schoolyard game of cooties there are
certain people you just can't talk to
because you'll catch their disease and
it's like actually that's not how it
works you can talk to people who with
whom you disagree and you can actually I
mean the whole process of intellectual
dialogue of dialectic is to gain from
the conversation that which you didn't
know that's actually valuable and reject
that part that isn't and persuade the
other person of something so the whole
idea that we shouldn't be talking to
these people because they are beyond the
pale is preposterous on its face
likewise the idea that free speech is
all well and good but there are certain
ideas that shouldn't be voiced these
things are they're transparent nonsense
is there some biological analogy you can
give me for what Eric just laid out
there so for the two of us that get as
you said catapulted out of this thing
that we end up in a new space and now we
see some some decency there so then it
the ideas start spreading there there's
got to be some biological something
there well in some ways this is a brand
new situation it would be very unusual
for an ancestral human to have been
ejected from their group and to find a
home in another group that's not
typically the way it works that
typically being ejected from your group
is a fatal circumstance that is much
less true the world we live in is very
unusual because reciprocal altruism is
really it has taken over and in some
ways you know this is dicey because you
have antecedents in the Torah
but the New Testament actually
prioritizes reciprocal altruism across a
larger group now it's clearly not
Universal because when the Christians
get to the new world they treat the
people in the new world as if they're
not part of the same species but but
nonetheless the ability to forge a union
that is not based on genetic lineage is
novel on the other hand it's also
beautiful that there is a kind of if it
were genes we might call it hybrid vigor
but there's a way in which you take
people who bring different kinds of
wisdom from different traditions that
have faced different challenges and you
put them together and you get
superpowers so anyway it is very
exciting to see it what-whatever but I
would say but but I think what you're
saying is that starting to happen right
now right well I would because there's
something now that's clearly to me far
bigger than any of us happening for the
amount of people that were are there
watching this live or will watch this
that will then spread some of these
ideas and realize that they're not the
hostages the intellectual hostages that
they think they are well maybe there's a
missing piece here which is our economic
system when you plug it into certain
things very directly like journalism I
think activist is your pointer read from
that it's truth seeking which cannot
withstand direct contact with market
forces that when you do that you
generate artificially feeble truth
seeking mechanisms and it eventually
invades them all so how hard is it to
beat the mainstream news outlets not
very hard because they're so bad at
delivering hearted analysis it's very
hard to beat them at at some kind of
competition right competitively they're
extremely dominant but in terms of what
they're trying to deliver they're
they're terrible likewise the university
system and so you know what what we're
you know to return to the conversation
of a few minutes ago the authoritarians
confront people most people capitulate
because it's just cheaper and they don't
have anything worth fighting over
those people who don't capitulate turn
out to be intellectually interesting for
reasons that have nothing to do with the
issue they were confronted over why is
that
it's because all of those fields have
become stuck the market forces have
caused them to adopt some wrong
assumptions and then to be unable to get
out of the cul-de-sac and so feeble
fields result in people quietly
inventing a better path that never gets
traction but is very powerful in terms
of understanding what's true and so
anyway the conversation you're talking
about is it's marvelous to be a part of
it but I think it's basic nature is that
a lot of people have privately invented
some part of the right answer and they
are now finding each other by virtue of
technologies that you know didn't exist
right yeah this part you have that part
the only thing that I'm worried about
and I don't know how to get around this
is there's this phase 1 phase 2 problem
we're in phase 1 phase 0 you're like I'm
the only person out here I don't know of
anybody else I can talk to and then in
phase 1 you sort of say okay well I
found you we have to talk about the fact
that ideas are being suppressed rather
than investigated and found wanting so
that's the one we've been in for yeah
and then we need to kick this out into
the next phase which is oK we've got the
channels we've got some audience I think
I personally am predicting that very bad
things are gonna start to happen to some
people in this network as the world
discovers how how powerful this medium
is because it's going to be very
disruptive the next what is that
actually well I'll come back I'll come
back to it because I don't wanna get
derailed okay
the next phase of this should be okay
what is it that you're building this
vehicle to deliver like what is wrong
with economics what is wrong with
biology what is wrong with physics what
is wrong with our you know theories of
spirituality and religion what are the
then beyond the ante theories which is
just like mmm-hmm you know how can I say
that string theory has been a disaster
in physics without immediately getting
trampled by by the stream string
theorists who have been in control of
this disaster the next thing is okay
well what is the positive theory that
goes in that place what what should we
be doing instead it's one thing to say
you know it's it's terrible that we're
being demonetised on YouTube or that
we're being down ranked on Twitter which
we didn't know was there word for shadow
banning or whatever it is okay we have
to stop bitching and whining about that
and start to say let me tell you what
I'm absolutely excited about here's
here's something that's never happened
before and it belongs to our group
so like fundamentally the telomere stuff
if that turned out to be right that this
is affecting drug testing maybe we could
save lives maybe some of the some of the
issues with you know damage to the heart
and because the heart's peculiar nature
of not having a ton of mitosis or
whatever it is you know it's an unusual
histological repair profile maybe we
could actually you know heal some some
some some families and and keep some
drugs from being released that have to
be recalled later
that's exciting maybe if we could
prevent particular interests from
playing around with the CPI you know you
had piya my wife on the program you know
she she released this amazing theory in
her thesis that never got taken up in
economics because it interfered with a
cryptic attempt to raise taxes and slash
benefits and you know it's sitting out
there in the open the h-1b visa that I
took on you know in the 90s is a
conspiracy that came out of the National
Academy of Sciences and the National
Science Foundation to attack the wages
of American scientists on behalf of
scientific employers I've had a working
paper for 10 20 years something like
that out on the web that nobody has
argued with strongly and just sits there
where no news media wants to touch it
because the h-1b is some part of the
protected narrative and now it has
nothing to do with being against
foreigners it just has to do with you
know a conspiracy inside of the Science
Complex and we could be talking about
any one of a number of super interesting
issues as opposed to the suppression of
speech but I think we don't we don't get
into that I'm Curie
as to why and I would love to start this
next phase I actually have a sense of
why maybe we don't get there there's a
problem the scenario I laid out about
how people end up inventing their own
models to beat fields that have gotten
stuck causes a byproduct and the
byproduct is that when you when you look
at a field and you try to figure out
what's wrong with it
and you bang your head against the wall
enough to actually get there you end up
redefining terms throwing out
assumptions building new assumptions all
sorts of things then when you meet
somebody else and you start trying to
put forth the model that allows you to
solve certain important problems you
sound crazy
mm-hmm so for example I know because I
had to confront the problem that the
term heritable is a disaster that what
Darwin meant when he sent Herod said
heritable is not what we currently mean
and that the difference the fact that we
all think we slow it slowed it down for
us for some of the slower people here so
heritable ferreira cannot for me look
the common parlance the definition of
heritable just means something that you
passed down to to your descendants at
the point that DNA came to be understood
as a mechanism for encoding information
that then caused cells to make proteins
that that affect things that do things
the we made a terrible error and it's a
natural error which is that the elegance
of the genetic mechanism is so extreme
the beauty of the explanation of these
triplet codons specifying particular
amino acids that are then strung
together that that explanation is so
good right it's not murky at all it's
perfectly precise and it caused
biologists to say AHA that is Darwin's
this is a premature codification right
which happens in every field where you
find something beautiful and there's
this premature codification well now
we've got the story right because it's
paying dividends at such a high rate
when you first discover it right it's so
good that it can't possibly be mustard
building structure on top of it and this
is the language and so every time you
try to get in underneath that and say
maybe like I don't know what you're
about to say inheritable but you know
typical device that we use is maybe
there are two terms that are being
conflated into a single word computer
science term for this is overloaded so
that maybe the word heritable is
overloaded we actually mean multiple
things by the same term we don't realize
we have a confusion so there all of
these techniques for sort of unweaving
the frame of an idea but I'm going to
take you to I don't think that we
actually sound crazy I think that's a
story I think that with enough exposure
to any one of the people who know how to
do this reasonably well and have done it
a number of times yeah it's usually not
that the person sounds crazy that is the
portrayal no I'm saying something
slightly different I believe you're
correct that when you confront the field
that you've found a way to solve its
problems it doesn't want to hear it all
right
and it can't hear it in fact really the
people think you you you don't have it
you're wrong and you know very often
this comes in it you know this happened
with telomeres you're wrong and we
already knew what you just told and you
know you're on the right track when you
get those two at the same time what I'm
talking about is I mean let's take an
example okay that's just the this food
is lousy in such small portions yes
exactly it's exactly that
so Jordan Peterson and I overlap in a
particular place and we came there from
as far as I can tell
totally different routes he came there
from psych and he you know unlike almost
any psychologist he took evolution
seriously very wise of him because it's
an it's an evolutionary psych is an
evolutionary phenomenon
I came to psych from evolution because
if you want to understand human beings
and what they do in an evolutionary way
you have to understand a bit about
psychology that causes a lot of overlap
in terms of what we care about but
there's a lot of definitional stuff that
is not perfectly concordant because
we've each invented our own private
language now I've seen this private
language thing enough times to know that
that's a landmine waiting to cause
trouble and so what you have to do
doesn't matter there's nothing at
steak in terms of who gets to define
each term but you have to recognize that
some term that's important to both of
you will be differently defined and if
you don't if you don't iron that out it
blows up so anyway the the what am i
also right that this is a particularly
good example I hadn't really thought
about this
Jordan initially tripped a lot more of
my filters that there was something off
or wrong and you know I think that when
he when he had the the show first with
Sam Harrison that they'd arranged on the
issue of what truth is Jordan was
technically not right but it took a
while to understand that this guy was at
a deeper layer then even he could I mean
you know he can he can correct me if he
disagrees but he had a bit of a Ferrari
in a Volkswagen chassis and Ferrari
engine in a Volkswagen chassis and that
was very confusing because some of the
things that he was saying seem kind of
pretty good pretty good at pretty good
whoa that's a sour note pretty good
pretty good
you know the something tripped our
filters I think Sam is probably still
much less convinced that Jordan is
really onto something deep and I'm not
saying that I'm signing up for the whole
Jordan Peterson program but it's a good
example of how something that you know
to be true gets tested against something
that you're hearing for the first time
that person may not be saying it well
and that person may not be fully able to
explain it and over time as you start to
work out the kinks you realize that
person is really onto something
beautiful deep and profound and maybe
maybe I hadn't thought about when I said
that it sounds crazy
Jordan probably sounded a little bit
more off yeah I really don't put it on
me that I didn't get it I really don't
think he is the more I listen to him the
more I can map what he's saying and it
all checks out from the part that
overlaps with what I know and actually
his situation with Sam Harris is the
classic case Jordan
Peterson is optimized around a different
value function what he's trying to
accomplish yeah meaning exactly and Sam
Harris is a stickler
at this philosophic Ruth's first then
we'll get briny so of course there was a
train wreck now perfectly possible to
say ah you're optimized around X I'm
optimized around Y but we have a lot of
overlap in terms of objective and we can
just recognize the the discordance and
just solve it so I'm hoping that we will
get good at this so that we don't keep
tripping over things that become sacred
to each of us so that's the next step
then right for you if we have to get
into we did 0 1 right at 2 really it's
not just that we need answers we need to
get good at and I think what my job in
this is just getting all of you together
I think that's a piece you know I mean
I'm not going to be dropping down
anything like what Sam is doing or
Jordan no but I think I can help people
get some of these ideas and and use them
for themselves
why have you swapped me out and put in
Richard Dawkins in this chair and you
just forced these guys to go hard on
evolutionary theory my guess is that
Dawkins is both at the very top yeah
people who've developed important
concepts like memes or extended
phenotype or whatever but on the other
hand his particular hobbyhorse against
religion is probably some sort of
intermediate product on the way to where
he's going and he's I feel like he's
stalled out there so I think that would
be a super productive conversation maybe
Brett turns out to just be wrong about
this stuff but that's a place where you
have to top minds on the same topic who
are discordant and almost certainly they
need to encounter each other to find out
you know is Dawkins really correct that
this is a mind virus or is Brett really
correct that this is some sort of
positive coevolution is there anything
you think that these systems can do I
mean I to me we're watching all the
systems collapse you talk about the
education system vitami we're watching
the media system collapsing the
political system collapse I think it
seems like everything is sore when I
watch sports now it doesn't seem the
same something seems old and corroded
ESPN is having a ton of trouble like
there's just so much crumbling at once
can these things all be fixed together
or I think that's the only way that's
the
is that we have to be bold enough to
imagine our way to a truly different
structure without and this is key you
can't screw this one up you can't a lot
of people believe civilization will
collapse and then we'll put the right
thing in place that is not going to
happen we have to protect civilization
enough that it can carry us through the
bottleneck and that's the tricky part we
have to do that and you know the the
tools that you end up needing are on the
one hand they're daunting to people the
tools you need to think about these
things on the other hand when you get to
them they're actually simpler than you
think
and they simplify your life in other
words most of us are carrying around too
many different kinds of concepts to
understand our own lives if you swap in
a little bit of game theory and it
doesn't take much you know there are
four or five fundamental games that just
change the way you see almost all human
interaction if you know what those are
and you spend the few hours necessary to
understand how they work so that you can
walk through the world and look at
puzzles and say ah this one is failing
because it's a race to the bottom here
you have a free rider problem once you
can just spot those things you realize
that most of the design space in which
we might build civilization is
effectively empty it can't be inhabited
because what you would build there even
if it was nice wouldn't be stable so the
answer is limited to that small number
of things that both accomplish what you
want them to accomplish and are stable
enough not to be destroyed as part of
the issue that the people that are gonna
actually do these things you know it's
like our conversation a couple months
back when we were talking about the bull
in the china house and I said to you
well what you're asking for is a panther
you want to have a china shop and a
panther to walk in and gain one thing
off and knock another thing off with its
tail and then walk out what we got in
Trump right and we don't have to make
this specifically about Trump but that
the people who will come in and fix
these systems if not these two great
people I'm sitting between are going to
be the bull in the china shop
well you guys are trying to fix things
manage things without having
civilization crumble at the same time
that the thing that we want is sort of
not the thing
you get in an odd way well so like I got
teased mercilessly because I said that
that your Panther and the china shop was
was one of the wisest things anybody
said to me and I think I get one what
every ten years you
we need the Panther in a china shop and
the fact is that the system that we're
in won't let in a panther
so that's Trump then right I mean that
full of planes Trump yeah but the
problem the problem with Trump is the
Trump revealed the weakness in my
position so I voted I said Trump is an
existential risk I took a lot of heat
because I worked for a guy who supported
Trump in the election
I voted Bernie then I voted Hillary and
I thought okay well if you really
believe that you're dealing with orange
Hitler and that we're playing with
nuclear annihilation the Democratic
Party should say look we've lied about a
number of things the big three for me
our immigration trade and terror and
let's dig up the bodies in the back and
say you know maiya culpa we did some
wrong things we have to re-establish
trust because we cannot afford to be
playing this game and when I saw that
the Democratic Party wanted to double
down and had no intention even though
they were claiming that we were on the
brink of annihilation and that Russia
was invading the country through the
election and all these terrible things
the places where I could check here's
something positive you could do to
reestablish trust you know it was a
narrow election could almost almost won
it it became clear that they don't get
it and that my hope and I think Sam
Harris is hope for example that we can
subtly reestablish trust within the
institutions by small modifications by
tweaking expertise rather than really
thwacking it is not possible unless you
and I and some other people are somehow
full in saying the expertise during this
period of time from 1980 to 2008 got so
polluted against across all institutions
that were playing these Ponzi scheme
games to keep the plates spinning this
is like a bad batch you're gonna have to
throw out tons and tons of bottles of
wine because they're all not workable
and there's a tiny amount of stuff that
was workable but the institutions turned
on all of those people so you're going
to have to seat people the panthers are
are in general what I call anti experts
they're people who usually have the
credentials they're known in the
community people are very uncomfortable
with them they'll talk to them privately
but they won't seat them on the main
stage and you know some of these people
are very tough to deal with and you know
I I I got in a seem to lab in front of
Congress and the seam is a very tough
people for a person for most people to
deal with but the fact is is that he's
just as Jordan Peterson says ultimately
one of the most disagreeable people
around and these public's minded he
wants to protect the system against
crazy risk-taking by bank heads who get
the profits and then socialize the
losses and the risk and okay so you know
you're gonna sort of keep this guy off
to the side where everybody knows his
name but nobody wants to deal with them
well this is kind of a profile who are
the people who the system discarded
between 1980 and 2008 for standing up
and who have some you know track while
he's an egotist he doesn't publish she
fundamentally is talking in her own
language
those tells are the people that need to
be back introduced back into the system
if we're going to get the Panther effect
so just to be clear though so in terms
of Trump it seems to me that he is one
of those guys whether you like him or
not he was one of those guys that was on
the outside saying something he was that
was a kind of real well they're logs
right he said a lot just but he just
went in with a sledgehammer so him
intuition yeah take a very simple one
I'm not saying he's a great ed but as
Jordan has said right here you know the
guy's obviously a lot smarter than
then most people are coming nobody I'm
not claiming that he lucky he has a
certain kind of genius and I haven't
backed off of that and he's got a lot of
intuitions not all of which are wrong
I'm not I'm that's not the issue the
issue is this is some surgical stuff if
you're going to fundamentally try to fix
let's say America's immigration issues
you've got to go in there with a surgery
you know nano knife and be very very
careful because our country is
multicultural it is never going to be a
white nation ever it's never gonna
happen and the way in which people who
would into it that something is wrong
with our immigration policy and there's
Intuit that it's been used but they
can't ground that in some sort of
analytic framework deal with it sooner
or later you start hearing these you
know like well the Mexicans are sending
us their rapist well are there some
rapists that are being sent we're coming
from Mexico yes but you cannot you can't
do that without destroying the fabric of
this country and you know this is where
I it's a pleasure to antagonize the far
right you know the Richard Spencer
fantasies about racial purity the amount
of violence you would have to use if you
tried to implement that let along the
fact that it's a terrible idea would be
so enormous we don't even know what
these people are talking and it's
important that you don't flirt with this
you don't want more than a thousand
people in the country carrying around
you know citronella candles and saying
things about blood and soil that's a
very dangerous idea to fan the flames up
and so you know the thing that I
personally had the hardest time with
trump on was during the campaign he said
this thing about we used to have a
beautiful system if we had protesters at
a political rally we'd rough them up and
if you do that I'll pay your legal bills
I thought did you just
seriously write a blank check and if
there's some crazy person here who
chooses to you know stick a knife in
somebody you're gonna pay that person's
legal but that was the moment I realized
that no matter what he might get right
and no matter what he might into it
he's playing
a kind of sloppy game with the world
that's Russian roulette and we can't
have somebody in that office playing
that game
just the way we can't have a Hillary
Clinton servicing this crazy narrative
that gets us deeper and deeper in
intellectual debt right so I guess what
I'm saying is that to me all the good
reasons that you guys are sitting here
and we're in the midst of this idea
revolution is because of the mess that
he has now sort of created versus if
Hillary was in charge I think all of our
positions right now would be much worse
because we'd be thought of as crazier
rightly right if the all those
institutions had just been faithfully
it's good for on easily propagated you
know by her well then for us locally but
we've got two completely unacceptable
alternatives in the system and it's this
issue of just saying I'm sorry if it's a
multiple choice I refuse to answer this
I'm not penciling anything in here
because it's neither Hillary nor is it
Trump it's fundamentally asking the
question who admits to being confused
who has the ability to think reasonably
clearly who has the ability to steal man
to echo to go metacognitive and I don't
see those skills here so I think that
you have more comfort with this than I
do yeah I think he has those skills I'm
just saying the room for those skills if
this is proof of it something has made
room here yeah
to say that that just seems obvious me
I'm not I'm not applying those skills to
him I don't even know if it was
intentional by I'm just saying it's
pretty obvious to mantich of the feeble
aspect of the system correctly spotted
that the thing was ripe to go after and
he correctly understood that he could
effectively be a third party candidate
inside of the Republican Party and win
whatever works right never works so
there's a kind of you know there's a
kind of genius a strategic genius there
but the point is what is the objective
of the exercise and I think it's really
to displace the rent-seeking elites with
a different alternative set of
rent-seeking leads and so that's not
progress it's not the panther in the
china shop by any stretch now it does
open the door here too
the conversation that we're having as
you're arguing but I would argue that
there's a there's this metaphor that we
use over an evolution space and
economists have made a lot out of it the
adaptive landscape in which
opportunities or niches are represented
as Peaks and the bigger the volume of
the peak the more opportunity there is
there and then the obstacles to getting
to a new peak are valleys and the deeper
the valley the harder it is to cross
this actually turns out to be useful for
understanding all kinds of transition
transitionary phenomena you know that
explains how you get from one squirrel
species to the next but it also explains
what it's like to go from a system like
ours that has become rickety across
every important structure to a new
system that wasn't like that what would
it be like well you're gonna have to go
through a heck of a valley what's that
gonna feel like well it might feel like
you're electing somebody like Trump
who's playing recklessly with you know
nuclear standoffs and things like this
and that the opposition is incapable of
doing anything but even in the face of
somebody who would who would play
nuclear chicken they're still on about
you know Hitlerian stuff that clearly is
not it doesn't accurately map to the
situation at all and so that yeah that
is what the adaptive Ally sounds like as
you begin to head into it sounds
incoherent and that's where we are the
incoherence is making room for a
coherent conversation and I don't know
maybe there are others but somehow we're
at the epicenter of one of those
coherent conversations do you believe
that I mean this is one of the questions
that I have where are the other groups
of people who are willing I mean
wouldn't we be able to hear them from
where we are well I think some of them
exist I mean some of them have sat here
that aren't traditionally in this space
you look at guys like Jason Whitlock and
clay Travis who come from the sports
world who were calling this out from
what they do I would say sort of that
they're so close you know that yeah I
mean where are these people I don't know
I look I'd be happy to have any of them
right here you know I mean I think one
of the key questions is more of them we
should be finding more of them in the
universities is one of the great
disappointment
or the issue that a lot of us are
extremely angry at journalists and
journalism but it's not because we don't
want journalists in journalism right
you're crowding out journalism yeah you
need to not stop journalism from
occurring by saying that you're a
journalist and keep doing hit pieces
against the people who are actually
trying to hold power to account mm-hmm
either you hold power to account or stop
hitting the people who are gonna try to
hold power to can stop defending power
by pretending to hold power to account
by going after the challenges and it's
not only that it's when we talked about
the different kinds of fake news and
when everything was happening with you
at Evergreen well how many stories did
the New York Times do on it stories not
told op-eds they did on and it was a
pause and it was very late into the
early when that's late and it was
completely at odds with what the the
editorial page had twice gotten right so
yeah it was it was a bizarre thumbs up
his or at all I would have absolutely
right this is what you've been saying
your ever I did predict you did predict
because Brett's story was
counter-narrative and almost perfectly
counter-narrative he could have gotten a
story about this had he screwed up and
said something slightly stupid and then
the story would have been largely about
that but by not saying anything stupid
by facing down this mob as an
anti-racist and the fact is the mob was
racist the whole thing was exactly wrong
and therefore it could not be reported
and that's why it didn't occur even
though the school I mean it was on
lockdown and they didn't report it so
it's like clearly a news story I mean
the school experimented with bigotry
driven anarchy and the president told
the police not to intervene that story
is simple I mean it was two sentences
and not understood by people that that's
what took place so I think what a lot of
people would wonder then is how does
this happen across the board basically
like every like for example just in the
last two weeks where Jordan really has
now skyrocketed a new level virtually
every article that I've read about him
and usually they're from websites that
you sorta maybe have heard about that or
whatever but pretty much all of them are
bad or they're straw Manning him or
they're saying awful things about him or
it's you know he's part of this you know
Masaya Yeah right or simply the voice of
angry white man yeah there's all these
angry white man meanwhile I went to his
big last week at the Orpheum here it was
completely diverse group of people right
they were having an absolute ball people
were out there in the audience with
giant lobster hands on I mean people
having fun it was like going to a
sporting event really but what does it
say that all of it it's not just the New
York Times in CNN you know my favorite
to to attack but it's that everywhere
was all the reporting that should have
been right on this where was the where
was all the lefty where was Mother Jones
and everybody else that should have been
defending you at the the progressive guy
at the progressive school who is doing
progress so in fighting racism where how
does that happen to across the board so
first of all part of the problem is that
in order for certain processes to take
place there has to be no reliable venue
that you can go to to get the
alternative story and so I don't know
how it is that Mother Jones is
compromised I must say that hurts that
Mother Jones is compromised this is a
publication yeah it's to be something we
depended on exact they called me further
to the right than bright I remember the
Isaac so what happened to Mother Jones I
don't know it's one of two things either
was compromised by some sort of
intentional plan to compromise it or it
got compromised by I mean there's
actually an intermediate it could have
been compromised by forces that drove it
into foolishness or the hybrid is that
some thing it may not even be a
conscious entity it may be an emergent
to something but some thing knows which
narratives threaten it and it poisons
them and the thing is human beings be
precisely because a human being cannot
survive on their own nor can they
ordinarily switch lineages people are
terrified of being isolated from the
group that is keeping them afloat and so
that they carry that with them when they
go to their jobs and journalism and so
what kind of noises do you have to make
before Mother Jones recognizes that
there's no niche for telling a story in
which the bigots happen to be bigots of
color that's not a story that plays well
on the left and Mother Jones doesn't
play well on the right so exactly who
would they be telling that story they
put themselves potentially out of
business and the same thing that you
know you
find that you know one of one of the
theories I have is the great oppression
shortage which is that we had thought
that if we could get rid of really
serious amounts of oppression we get a
much more diverse outcome and it hasn't
it's gotten better by a lot but it
hasn't gone far enough for a lot of our
tastes this is a puzzle and it's am
uncomfortable puzzle you know but I
think we should be working on it and say
okay is there more seriously structural
oppression that we didn't catch are
there some moves that we didn't you know
so I've made the point repeatedly that
maybe we have to pay women more because
the burden of kin work of young children
and elderly parents has been following
on female shoulders you know I'm
certainly willing to experiment with
fairly radical ideas but when I will
never do is mandate equality of outcome
or pro-rata shares of the population
because this that you know that's insane
and it will cause all sorts of terrible
things to happen now I think what has
happened is is that we've gotten very
terrified of where are we you know why
is it that we didn't get a bigger
dividend in diversification it's pretty
good but it's not as good as it needs to
be okay that's fair but we should be
thinking about it and instead this
there's this idea of let's run it
backwards and we'll say that whatever
the extent is that the the field doesn't
represent the pro-rata shares that's a
high end field that is the level of
oppression well I just want to go back
and clean up something this actually is
the reason that you have to fix the
question of heritability and I know that
Sam sounds like it comes out of nowhere
at this point but the problem is that
genes are not synonymous with
heritability there are multiple layers
of heritability including all of this
cultural stuff and the point is we've
never figured out how those things
interact and I think I know how they
interact but we've never agreed on it as
a field once you do understand that
actually there's a necessary way that
culture and genes and other epigenetic
phenomena interact you will discover
that
there is a a logic to why things fail to
correct when you solve these structural
obstacles to diversity so recognizing
that actually we were paying attention
to too small a set of things to actually
solve the problem is key but we can't
even have that conversation yet because
when you say you know that something is
heritable you immediately invite a
terrible confusion in the organs that
should be discussing this are just not
equipped intellectually to address a
problem like black racism against
White's which you know is a feature of
the world or you know we've created this
very unrealistic picture of male-female
relationships which doesn't have a very
realistic picture of either men or women
and you know we're shying away from the
intellectually difficult conversations
and we're having the socially and
politically very difficult conversations
but you did this to me no I didn't yes
you did and you know we're using a ton
of energy fighting around the
Thanksgiving family table but we're not
like getting quiet and getting
thoughtful and saying this is pretty
interesting we didn't expect to be here
how do we go further and none of I don't
think Mother Jones or NPR or CNN or the
New York Times is intellectually
equipped plus we have this that
different problem that at least in the
case of something like the New York
Times you've got this Democratic donor
class that doesn't I think have standard
Democratic interests at heart and it has
to figure out how do we keep getting
whatever tax exemptions or favorable
treatment we need by extolling something
that sounds vaguely progressive and so
you've got this face that is shown to
the world that doesn't really look like
what's powering it you know and that's
where like the super-delegates and all
anger against Debbie wasserman-schultz
came in which is like if you've ever
seen one of the end of it
you know for this much money you can
have you know 30 seconds and you can get
a photo taken it's like a menu of stuff
that makes you sick okay well why is
that it's because fundamentally it's
very expensive to say let's fix the
problems of working America and let's
actually ask if we're at a low growth
environment what does that mean do we
have a plan can we fix our institutions
do we need to come up with more growth
do we need to invest in research and
development to have a broad
technologically led growth revolution to
you know to raise people up
that's not guaranteed to work are we
going to take risk together are we going
to come to some kind of common cause are
we going to be able to live with the
fact that inequality is always going to
be present there's no way to banish it
you don't want to get rid of it but you
do want to get rid of the inequality
that comes from well who is who's got
the sharpest elbows to who's been using
them to outmaneuver the sharpest minds
let's go depressing for a moment all
right if we don't do any of this if we
don't and all of your efforts are futile
what does that actually look like
because I think a cert amount of people
that have jobs and struggle and gotta
pay the bills and everything they can
tune in to some of this conversation
we're sort of in it all the time right
but they can tune in to a little bit and
be like ah maybe I could speak up more
or maybe I could share this video more
or tell my cousin about this this or
that but for the average person I don't
think they really know what to do what
if we just kind of fail what does that
actually look like let's scare some
people into waking up then now it's not
my usual tactic absolutely I think the
the problem that we face is that we we
are mapping what's going wrong at the
wrong level and we see dozens of things
that don't work and we imagine dozens of
solutions that we would have to come up
with and that's not what's going on
what's going on is actually one or a
couple of things are way off and they
were causing a symptoms to emerge across
the the body politic and across
civilization if we don't do anything the
power of the tools that we are now
playing with technologically and the
number of people on the planet and the
just a simple quantity of resources that
they utilize in a lifetime
take off the map because they can't be
recovered that will doom us how will it
doom us well we may not get to
starvation because we have an AI problem
that nobody's figured out how to address
will you get an economic collapse that
will cause warfare that goes nuclear
that's quite possible will you fail to
notice the danger of a Carrington event
taking out transformers that could
literally knock out a third of the
country's Electric Power for six months
well that's bad but it's not nearly as
bad as the fact that we have nuclear
power plants depending on that power and
if you don't continue to feed them
electric power and you don't get them
diesel fuel in time they turn into
nuclear volcanoes so basically what
we've built is a system that is ultra
fragile and the solution involves
recognizing that you don't want to go
after these things all a cart you want
to go after them all at once you want to
recognize what the you know to use your
turn the generating function is that has
caused all of these fragile systems to
be erected without anybody building the
proper protections into them and then
the question is well what would you have
to do to address that core function just
to patch the stuff that needs to be
patched to address the core function so
it doesn't produce any more of these
things and then over time replace the
fragile parts of the system with
something reasonable is there a time
that this has ever been done correctly I
mean like I can think you know okay the
Enlightenment we got good ideas that
expanded freedoms right and expanded
intellect and science and things like
that yeah but this is a very different
thing we're talking about truly well I
mean the physical nature of what we have
yeah I think you know look you can I
could easily imagine the week squeeze
300 more years with good luck out of
this world by repeatedly getting lucky
through event after event and but I
don't think I don't think we'll get 300
more years and I do think that if we
don't change if we don't update for
where we actually are we're not going to
have the right mind
working on the right problems and I
think there's two levels of the problem
the first is that almost nobody's
allowed to actually talk and think about
where we are with institutional support
so if you want to remain in the good
graces of the institution's which is the
best plan we have and I don't know how
to make this work you have to
fundamentally start letting in the
people who the institution's absolutely
under all circumstances want out so this
is sort of this is sort of us in a sense
and why notwhy rogen isn't on television
or something like that at a very I'm
giving you a simplest can be I fear
factor right but he can't be talking
about the need to get ayahuasca to
troops of PTSD right as a normal thing
on cable television offers that we don't
know about I don't right yeah well I I
don't know either or you know Ben
Shapiro so so previously we've said this
thing about Real Time with Bill Maher
has been the airlock between the world
of kids with YouTube stations with
really interesting ideas and grownups
with institutional support who can't
talk about real ideas very much okay and
then you know we saw what happened when
somebody like Milo started to go through
that airlock and you can be a fan of
mile or not a fan of Milo but they
picked him off with yeah old footage
that had been out there for forever
because he threatened to break in so
might claim to you earlier is is that I
believe that almost all of us as we
start to gain traction will be picked
off because the fragile nature of our
institutions doesn't want to be in
conversation you get the Kathy Newman
Jordan Peterson interaction and suddenly
it's an unscripted event and the
Challenger you know who's a 97 pound
weakling defeats the sumo wrestler and
it doesn't look good right so assume
that you could actually get the right
iconoclasts the right challengers seated
at the table who would change the nature
of the discussion because you can't have
these discussions about you know string
theory a great theory or the greatest
theory that's like the typical debate
debate you what you would typically have
and like why have we wasted 30 to 40
something that is clearly not panning
out is a different kind of a discussion
with that kind of thinking the next
question is if we confronted that we
might have a low-growth world that we
have growth predicated institutions and
that we may have a climate change
problem but it's not so easy to dial
back carbon emissions because carbon
emissions are almost synonymous with an
economic growth and you might have
warfare on the one side versus
despoiling your planet on the other side
so it's not just like you know fewer
pool plastic pool toys from China but
actual war you know counterbalancing the
the issues with the environment then you
have this question like no we don't know
we may not be able to solve these
problems but at least you'd have people
working on them and I think to Brett's
point about you know like I have no idea
how to diagnose our nuclear power
stations and how much of a risk and
whether they're on fault lines or their
tsunamis by the sea it you know until we
had Fukushima I had I had no idea that
that was you know a real thing we are
probably going to rely on some close
calls maybe there will be a ballistic
missile that gets fired and suddenly
people will stop saying oh you know
they're just posturing and North Korea
is really just trying to do this for
economic concessions and it'll all be
fine
because it hasn't all been fine since
1945 it's pretty much all been fine at a
global scale we haven't really restarted
history in earnest in that way for so
long and that allows people to do some
sort of extrapolation from the data but
you know as earnest a friend Nassim says
is that the turkey thinks the farmers is
best friend right up until Thanksgiving
there's a there's another aspect to this
so I often find that people who are
interested in thinking deeply about the
future are often divided into two camps
there are those who are motivated by
fear and there are those who are
motivated by hope and the problem is
trying to talk to them simultaneous
right right if you talk to the people
who are motivated by fear you destroy
your ability to talk to the folks
were motivated by hope and vice-versa
but there is a way in which there's sort
of a I can't I can't be certain but the
force that has kept things from changing
substantially the force that has kept us
on this trajectory is on the one hand a
very dangerous force and it's very
tempting to anthropomorphize it I
personally actually call it Goliath but
Goliath is not a creature right it is
not a creature it behaves sort of like a
creature in many ways but it is actually
composed of various things various
emergent phenomena there are people who
staff Goliath and they have a
perspective on things and I think it is
important actually maybe to try to get a
message to people who may not even
realize they're part of it but the
message is something like this the
process of transitioning to a world that
functions is on the one hand daunting on
the other hand it would be pretty
exciting to live in that period of
transition and it would give people I
mean we're talking about a process that
would take several generations I'm
pretty sure to get there but we have a
planet of seven and a half billion
people most of whom have nothing
meaningful to do right that doesn't have
to be that way and creating the will to
change means actually living in a much
more vibrant time that is much more
rewarding it would be much more
rewarding to live in what's more many of
the people who have been committed to
this trajectory are bound to be noticing
the same fragility that we are all
noticing and they may be ready actually
to recognize that the transition would
require some unusual kinds of thought
processes things that they don't they
can't source at the university level
very easily and so so you can sort of
get them to a place where they'd have to
jump ship the question is to be how do
you bootstrap with effort to re-envision
civilization well it's going to involve
some stuff that doesn't sound right it
first going outside of the institutions
looking at people who you're gonna have
to work extra hard to figure out whether
they actually know anything but that
having done so there's more hope for the
future than there would otherwise be so
you know if the folks who are committing
us to this trajectory have kids and
grandkids
well they might wake up and they might
recognize actually it's time to do
something different because call to
adventure I mean you know one of the
things is that I think we are both the
hope and fear people like this is pretty
depressing to even even to be on the
other hand I know that we're we're
probably gonna have one more
absolutely amazing drunken dinner I
guarantee it and you know the call to
adventure is incredibly interesting the
key problem for most people is that it's
not that they don't have anything
meaningful to do it's that they're
they're getting their meaning from the
fact that they're feeding a family by
doing something repetitive and if that
non-repetitive if that repetitive thing
can now be automated let's imagine
mm-hmm do we still want them to get
their meaning from doing some repetitive
thing or do we want them to do get their
meaning more people to to get it from
searching for something that is new to
try creation is there any way we can
fundamentally people talk about
redistribution of wealth I'm much more
interested in a redistribution of risk
taking ability if somebody has a great
idea and they need to be able to take
risk on it and they don't have the funds
then that idea dies with that person and
you know if the person who's making up
my hotel room
has a great idea and they can't afford
to pursue it I would like to
redistribute some of my ability to take
risks towards that person and that's
much more important than talking about
redistributing the fruits of labor
now if more people feel excited and this
is why we can't go to gloomy and doomy
because fundamentally even if it's the
end of history and it's the end of
humanity fundamental I'd love to have at
least the last stand and to fight
shoulder to shoulder in some meaningful
glorious decent way well I know you mean
it at the most personal level because I
think you've said this publicly but you
said to me privately in the midst
of your whole insanity at Evergreen you
said to me how proud you were to be
publicly standing with your brother that
is like this is this is meaningful
no this is meaningful and I think maybe
that's why I mean my show is funded by
patreon we don't you know these we're
putting all these videos out for
everybody but whereas a select group of
people who have said I want these things
to be heard so I don't pay I don't pay
for it how do I know that I'm actually
part of this I want to bleed with you
you know and because all of us are
taking risks some of us travel with
security details you know like I own for
example and you know there are multiple
ways to die and one way to die is you
know in your bed at 98 never having
risked or tried or cared about something
never being willing to gamble you know
with the full stack and I guess what I'm
what I'd love to see is you know that
energy that we saw remember going to see
Sam Harris and Richard Dawkins as your
plus-one and it was just like everyone
was introducing them Steve Rubin you
know can you sign this can you tagged in
a picture well how do we fundamentally
sort of open this up a little bit more
yeah because you know all the time
people are telling me look here are my
skills I'm a mechanical engineer I've
got a next wife and a kid and I have to
make certain payments but above and
beyond that I've got this many hours is
there anything I can do for you yeah and
we are not calling I remember that
moment after 9/11 where people wanted to
know what can I do
and somebody said go shopping yeah Bush
said go shoppin right well that was
wrong I remember when you know Katrina
hit we we all sort of said how do i how
do I get to Louisiana can I can I make
it happen I my partner and I you know
reached into her pocket just handed
somebody you know silly amounts of cash
because he was going to go down because
we wanted to be in and this urged to be
in and to do something to support people
who are taking risk is this buried thing
that the the institutions can't stand
because they're actually quite
vulnerable to it and that's why I like
you you see one of these articles on a
hit piece on Jordan the probably trainer
fire
in really funny picture reasons you know
there's one yeah with my friend Peter
teal we have this really strange
expression I like let me guess what
you're about to write about a person
who's always behaved decently and
generously to me you're gonna create
that character that you do yeah
which isn't a real person but the press
just loves it right and so each one of
us is gonna have our shadow character
which is how the press is going to see
us and our actions are gonna be
translated into that and I think Douglas
Murray said it best he said you know
it's just the waters not too bad
yeah and once you actually make it
beyond this okay so maybe they destroy
us maybe they write the headpieces maybe
they neutralize this as is their dream
but to have fought and to have people
who will actually stand I mean the best
part of standing up with breath or the
Evergreen thing was I didn't know
whether I buckle or fold I didn't know
whether you know every was saying well
Brett will apologize because they all
apologize you watch it's just a matter
of time and to actually fight feels good
yeah well that's why I feel like this is
personal for us like but I don't even
mean just but evergreen I mean this
whole damn thing or believe me it's
there like this is it I wake up it's
what's on my mind I go to sleep it's
what's on my well I wish that I mean to
be entirely honest I wish that I want to
get back to actually solving the
problems that the battle is crowding out
so you know I've been trying to push out
all of my techniques for unspinning the
news because even though you know I'm
very proud of like the four quadrant
model and the Russell conjugation and
all and all of that theorizing but I
want other people to operate
operationalize it and build computer
models where you can get machine
learning there's this new thing the
knife media mm-hm you know maybe this
has a little bit of a shadowy backing it
backer but so far whatever the product
has been really good so I just treat it
like the Christian Science Monitor I
don't believe in Christian Science but
that was a pretty good
and they are trying to unspin the news
using everything of mine that they can
get their hands on and every
conversation with them they're just
absolutely genuine about detecting bias
and I would rather that if that's their
passion they take the models and run
with it and I get back to thinking about
how do we fix you know our theory of
economics or how do we figure out any
way around the Einsteinian speed limits
because that's that's really what I'm
supposed to be doing but right at the
moment I feel like our group has been
just fighting for the right to have a
space and to breathe and to disseminate
the fact that yes the whole narrative
structure is crumbling there's no way to
sustain it you can watch CNN and you can
just see it just doesn't make sense
anymore so I must say I'm a little bit
excited to see who will be discovered by
this process that you know there are
there are many more to come and it will
be interesting each one that shows up
brings something interesting to the
table I mean I can't wait just to open
my email after this because I get those
emails every day I'm an engineer I want
to help you on the graph I just know I
don't have to respond to them I don't
know what to do either we send them all
to a file we've got all of them but I
literally I mean I kid you not I'm not
being sarcastic we have literally
thousands of emails people saying I want
to get in this fight I don't know what
to do here are my skills well and that's
the thing is that this is actually a
characteristic that exists in lots of
people lots of people are actually
perfectly capable of being brave and
decent and given something worth
fighting for will do it and I think
that's actually what the the
institutions fear most is that they're
actually a lot of people sort of waiting
to be activated in that in that way
one caution that I would offer is that
there is a very uncomfortable period at
the point that you have been identified
and it attempts to disincentivize you
continuing in that direction yeah many
people not realizing that they feel like
they've they're hanging by their fingers
from the cliff and the reverse course so
Chelsea Manning did this recently um you
know she got spooked off of hanging out
with the wrong folks and retreated and
turned on them which was a terrible
error
um and so anyway the advice is if you're
going to stand up you will be targeted
and it will be very uncomfortable but
you have to stick to it long enough to
get across the gap if you don't get
across the gap you will have the
six-digit out yeah yeah head your dad if
you're gonna go you're gonna go you have
to go yeah so did you realize that
immediately like I mean the the places
that put you on we're basically Fox and
other right-wing places in that evil
Rubin report and etc etcetera did you
immediately say that okay if I'm doing
this I have to do it well you got to
understand this this goes back to what
Eric was saying at the beginning this is
not the first one of these that we've
encountered and they're all different
right this one was way different I was
not expecting to become well-known as a
result of alleged racism I mean that
just sounds like a preposterous eternal
for my life to have taken but yeah but
nonetheless the experience once you
survive one you know something that only
the tiny percentage of the population
knows which is that there is you can do
you can get across and having gotten
across you never want to go back because
you're free and so anyway the point is
people are carrying this huge cognitive
load because they're not free to think
to see to do all those things and the
the cost to shed that load is not small
but having said it you can live without
it once you've paid the price of the
attempted stigma and it's fallen short
you can then stare down other stuff
absolutely I love that I mean that
that's what we've been looking for right
like that's it that's when Douglas said
the waters not too cold I mean that's it
get on the other side you will somehow
survive or not I mean look III don't
know K I don't want to sell ya because I
can tell you I mean I've been I've been
sick to my stomach
I've been absolutely terrified when you
know when I hit peace is done on you or
your friends and you know suddenly
everybody's talking about the hit peace
you have the feeling that your your life
is over and it's not for the faint of
heart I don't want to incentivize people
isn't it you know go ahead make nobody
is nobody saying it's safe nobody say
Yeah right but what what it is is it is
often survivable and you know I make
this joke that before I traded in my
respectability I was cowering in front
of department heads and after I traded
it in I started flying around in private
jets hanging on private islands because
in part there is this network of people
who thinks for themselves in a way that
is absolutely repugnant to the
institutions and there are resources and
there are opportunities it's very
difficult but I want to absolutely say
that there are no promises because if
you don't do it well you know you should
not just stand up and you have to think
that you can possibly make the jump and
you have to be prepared that you're
going to be smeared and that the smears
you know that and this is something I
wanted to bring up which is I've tried
to document the ways in which people
have been brought down before and the
last time we really cleaned house in the
intelligence community was in the mid
70s with the church and pike commissions
and we learned a ton about these
untraceable ways that Goliath which
sometimes is emergent and sometimes
conscious can take somebody down and you
don't realize that the story that got
written about you was planted by the
government and if that sounds crazy to
you you're you actually have a problem
because this is fully documented there's
no conspiracy theory this is conspiracy
fact what we don't know is what happened
since church Pike and this is why for
example the noonas memo you know I think
it's completely a partisan stunt but
it's a partisan stunt that may actually
have an underlying reality as well those
two things are not one you can't say
well it's because it's a partisan stunt
then I don't want
to investigate right and so you know
there's this thing where Eisenhower said
beware the military-industrial complex
complex in his final farewell address
and I would say that that needs to be
updated to be aware of what I call Tim
technology intelligence and media and
there is something about the fact that
all of our personal information is
housed on the servers of a few large
tech companies the intelligence
community has not been vigorously
vigorously vigorously investigated for a
very long time and the media is in some
sort of relationship to both of those
that we don't understand and so Mike my
real concern is is that the people who
threaten this dominant gated
institutional narrative have to beware
of Tim technology intelligence the media
working behind the scenes in ways that
we don't understand which is the
expectation post-church Pyke commissions
that is the default should be that this
is the way the world normally works
that wasn't an anomaly and if you
believe that that doesn't happen anymore
absolutely the burden of proof is on you
if you want to take it up please but
otherwise we have to imagine that
fundamentally we're all vulnerable to
having all of our our email on on in a
gmail account all of our personal
interactions in a Facebook account what
we are doing with direct messages being
read by Twitter engineers as per this
you know I don't love James O'Keefe but
he seems to have unearthed some stuff at
Twitter we should be very very worried
you followed him I mean I said that was
good what you last said yeah that was
pretty solid you guys are brothers I'm
not even sure where to go from here so I
think we've been going for about two
hours I think we can do about three I
think I feel there's more here I also
want to do some questions with the
audience where else am I not thinking
right now what are the spots that I'm
not thinking about because you know I
view most of this through such a media
political lens that when I hear the
parts that are your expertise I go wow
that's really
it's totally ancillary related to this
it's right on the level but it's a
little out of the lane that I usually
look in what else are people not
thinking about well one thing I would
just
out here that again this maybe this is
cleaning up from the beginning of the
conversation but Eric and I have a
little advantage which is that we don't
have two different languages Eric speaks
math in a way that I don't speak it but
because we've been keeping up with each
other
intellectually on stuff that matters
there is no distance to cover when you
know if I need to define some term in
some new way in order to address some
problem I can just say here's here's the
definition I need you to temporarily
accept so that is a kind of a model for
something that we need to bootstrap
where people don't have a sibling
relationship that would cause that kind
of alignment and the you know the
necessary tools involve high degrees of
tolerance the assumption that somebody
this is an assumption that does not work
on Twitter but the assumption that
somebody is making sense and if it
sounds like what they're saying does not
make sense then you haven't understood
it correctly yet they may be wrong but
they're not saying something look go
talk about Dumbledore sure okay go ahead
so a friend of ours Mike Brown would
lend us his island and we would run a
science camp on this island a friend
would lend you the island he's a good
friend and okay now this is like our our
subs are adopted uncle Christ a very
wise man and he was the CFO of Microsoft
and ran the Nasdaq and one of the rules
on the island is is that if you had a
group of really interesting people you
had to have two rules you need to have
two rules in order to have a productive
discussion one is is that a very smart
person was saying something obvious
should be assumed to be saying something
subtle until proven otherwise
and that an intelligent person who is
saying something that is wrong should be
assumed to be saying something
counterintuitive until proven otherwise
and that those two rules cleaned up a
lot of confusions so there are these
like hacks and tricks to make sure that
your conversations don't get
bogged down in displays of ego so you
know all of us when we're insecure we
start peacocking and you have to be able
to call each other out so you have to
have some terms to go metacognitive
another thing that I think we worked up
together but has another name sometimes
people call it the pre trans fallacy I
used to call it the victor/victoria
problem because of this movie
victor/victoria the story of a woman
playing a man playing a woman and so the
problem was is that if you saw a woman
did you see a female impersonator or did
you see a woman playing a female
impersonator right and so Brett's
version of this is the one that I use
the most because I think it's the best
which is is a whale of fish it's a very
innocuous question and almost everyone
is educated to give you this sentence
yes it's a mammal well that's certainly
true but is it a fit what is it a fish
see that I was giving you the most
simple answer is it a fish by what
definition makes something a fish so
this is the this is the middlebrow
answer than almost everyone gives and
the idea being that the lowest level you
know the Whalers used to say the whale
fishies because morphologically swim so
like a fish looks like a fish it's got a
tail obviously fish one level up from
that you say oh no it's a mammal it
crawled back into the sea many years ago
and evolved in water and breathes air
and rest live birth but the problem is
one level above that the thing reverses
back because you're bracketed on
Darwin's phylogenetic tree between
lampreys which are clearly fishes I'm
just all I'm doing bread is stealing
yeah and coelacanth let's say and so all
mammals are fishes and so if somebody
says that a whale is a fish you don't
know whether you're dealing with
somebody who's just completely
uneducated or somebody who does this for
a living
mmm-hmm and that confusion of not
knowing whether you're sophisticated
relative to somebody's point or
unsophisticated is one of the ways in
which great conversations just derail
mmm-hmm so you have to make a list of
everything that stops a great
conversation from occurring or another
one would be you know that you have one
term that's playing
two different roles you know like and I
think Daniel Dennett called this a
Dipity in one context or in another case
so sometimes you have to find two
dissimilar things that are the same
things when when when sourced from the
same abstraction other times you have to
Deacon fight two things that have the
same name so there's some large toolkit
from keeping high level conversation
from going awry that can be pushed out
but fundamentally you know you're no
longer in a position to teach this stuff
to students because you have to be
outside of the University and I think if
you look at Brett's situation in
microcosm you know what pressures is
jordyn under a Lindsay not to teach
something mm-hmm that's super
interesting and to compete in the world
of ideas
where will we teach this that's the
question sometimes we're teaching it
here yeah and the Rubin report by
example and I'm sure every time we make
a mistake somebody will note it and
they'll make that a little clip and
they'll play that in infinite rotation
which is a beautiful thing it can be
right I mean this is what you know
Peterson wanted to do the online
University Greg Gutfeld wrote a really
interesting piece I think he referenced
both of you guys actually in the piece
about how you know in college you can
learn some stuff from teachers but
there's so much wrong that you're being
taught now he said wait a minute you all
have YouTube you have an iPhone you can
download podcasts and it's like man you
can learn from Peterson and why it's
dine and why it's diet and whoever else
there is and the tools are yours you
might lose something by not be you know
the formative parts have grown it's like
raw milk cheese mostly it's delicious
and it's really really good and
occasionally there's a little bit of
danger so you know fundamentally if you
want pasteurized Kraft singles that's up
to you but you're not going to get the
good stuff are you not getting offers
left and right I have I mean I don't
know how much you're free to talk about
but you know it's like I would imagine
that there's got to be some grave
administrators out there brave you know
people that have the the donors and
everybody behind them are going holy cow
can we not stand for free speech and
free expression and bring in you know a
bright biologist as well I mean well I
did get an offer from a school in South
Carolina
that was nice I'm not in a position to
move my family to South Carolina but the
interesting thing is I'm getting tons of
offers but they're small offers to come
talk here they're to sit on a panel
these kinds of things in terms of
replacing the two incomes that my family
lost when we resigned from Evergreen
yeah to me I don't think a lot of people
know that part of it by the way your
wife resigned as well you weren't just
gonna leave her to be hung out to be dry
right there was no way I mean she was on
sabbatical as this whole thing unfolded
so in some way she was artificially
insulated from the meltdown that that
happened but there was no way for either
of us to stay on alone and um I have
zero regrets about leaving I miss
teaching but I have the sense that
things were so toxic and in fact I have
friends who are still on the inside who
send me updates on what's going on and
you know it's gotten worse they've
doubled down on every crazy how does it
say that I was warning you about this
for years you absolutely did warn me
about this for years in your point was
that a state a tenured position at a
State College seems like bedrock but the
way this could turn around and evaporate
out from under you will not be obvious
until it happens and then it did happen
so in any case yeah we lost both of our
income streams because Heather was
actually evergreens most popular
professor at the point that we resigned
I wasn't far behind but but that does
put the pressure on to figure out what
we do next and I will say people seem to
think that colleges should be vying to
hire us I have the sense that in fact
the whole thing unfolds as a kind of
double edged sword where on the one hand
I think we've established that we have
something valuable that we know how to
teach in a way that really gets students
motivated on the other hand I at least
publicly have demonstrated that I'm
willing to stare down the president of a
college and call him out for putting us
in danger
and there's a question about I guess
what kind of personality defect would
result in a person being willing to do
that and do I want to hire such a person
I don't think that's actually what's the
case but I do think somebody deciding to
hire me in particular is probably
running a cost-benefit analysis in which
even if they're favorable to the idea
their fear about what could unfold and
make them look terrible might be I'm
gonna challenge you a little bit all
right
fundamentally I don't think that the
issue should be whether they offer you a
position straight away I think that what
they don't know is is that they should
invite you to give a lecture on the
latitude diversity gradient they should
invite you to figure out will you give a
lecture on predicting radically
elongated telomeres from first
principles with jutsu breeding protocols
in laboratory mice they should ask you
what is it that we don't understand
about random mutation not being the
engine of selection there are all sorts
of technical puzzles that Brett's been
very active on where he may be right he
may be wrong but you have to actually
ask and what they're going to use that's
incorrect is they're going to use
publications and yes because
publications is this weird thing where
if you're in the group it's not that
hard to publish and if you're outside
the group you waste
infinite amounts of energy getting past
reviewers and the people who are in the
group say I don't understand why didn't
you publish your stuff but they don't
understand that fundamentally that it
works very differently whether you're in
group tore out grouped I believe that
the right thing to do is to have every
evolutionary biology department ask
itself the question have they invited
you to give a lecture on one of these
technical topics yes or no if no then
why not if yes what did you like what
didn't you like but fundamentally used
to be the case that you could have a
career and publish very little and have
very big ideals you know the Kirk girdle
published very little other public
people published a ton that's the thing
that hasn't happened and it's a sign
that fundamentally the department's
aren't feeling strong and vital because
who the hell is an administrator what's
a college resident right college
presidents or people who raise funds the
heart and soul of a great university is
a department chair with a middle finger
and a slush fund and says we don't care
about the administration we will sneak
you into this place the great days of
Columbia where when Isidor Rabi held a
little you know Enclave for everybody
was employed at the high schools or CCNY
who was worth their salt they could come
and play at Columbia because
fundamentally he was gonna
disintermediate the administration if
the administration is the gatekeeper of
your university you were a second-rate
institution fundamentally the power
either resides with the researchers and
the professors or it resides in
someplace that's not capable of keeping
up the standards of a great University
it's a very important distinction so
places like Chicago which are famously
disagreeable which have a bad attitude
are good places for somebody like Brett
in someplace that is fundamentally
trying to make itself look good in the
rankings and thinking about building
beautiful new buildings you know that's
not a great place and my question is how
many great universities do we have left
to have that courage to stand up where
the professor's are in charge and the
administrators of the service class so I
would also point out this this
publication thing is it's particularly
difficult because many good people think
you can use this as a proxy because in
general you can write somebody with no
publication record is often not serious
but in my case I did publish my telomere
paper and the story of what happened on
the road to getting it published and
then what happened after it was
published is so preposterous
that it resulted in my effectively
becoming allergic to the idea of playing
this game and the truth is I walked away
from my graduate program and I started
teaching and I kept doing my research
work but I wasn't really even interested
in having a degree from a system that
would behave this way on such an
important topic that actually
human health and the balance so there's
a way in which I don't think people know
exactly what to do with me I went back
and I got my degree at the point that
evergreen said we would like to hire you
permanently because you're so popular
with students but we can't hire you
unless you have a PhD for accreditation
reasons so anyway I did go back and get
the degree that was also an amazing
situation where you know I had polarized
my department how did I polarize my
department I polarized my department by
following things where they naturally
led and not being afraid to cross
disciplinary boundaries to address
questions which made me really popular
with some folks and really unpopular
with some other folks and you know at
the point that I went back to get my
degree my adviser dick Alexander and
Jerry Smith somebody who had been an
ally so paleolithic theologist came out
of retirement to fight a battle to get
me a degree and there's something I can
say on your behalf that you you're
really not in a position to so I I knew
Bret's advisor dick Alexander who one of
the great four or five evolutionary
theorists of recent times the guy who
predicted you social behavior and naked
mole-rats from first principles so
unbelievable intellect and I held a
conference at the Perimeter Institute
where we're gonna try to fix economics
by taking an interdisciplinary approach
and I got to know him a little bit and
he started talking to me about how Brett
was his top student and I said did did
you ever write this down he says no I
said will you write a letter of
recommendation for Brett telling me
where he stands I don't want to
influence at all and so he wrote this
beautiful letter of recommendation
saying you know I've been teaching for
4045 years whatever it is this is my top
student of all time and you know that
top student isn't interested in getting
a degree necessarily isn't interested in
necessarily expending more and more
energy on meaningless games with
referees at journals that are clearly
gated and now is the time to actually
reattach eep way to do this is just say
hey do you want to come give a
in our evolutionary theory group because
evolutionary theory as I tweeted
recently is always at odds with identity
politics because it fundamentally weaves
together diversity which they like with
differential success which is a proxy
for inequality with heritability which
is a proxy for privilege and so
evolutionary theory has been taking on
the chin intellectually lose swimming
upstream for a long time just how you
know fundamentally invite him for a talk
or don't but know why you did or why you
didn't and that's I think the right way
to begin the process but I've been not
very surprised but I've been very
disappointed that the university system
can't rally because evergreen was simply
farther ahead in a process that seems to
be affecting almost all institutions of
higher learning all right I want to get
to some audience questions because I
know we have a gajillion is there
anything else that you absolutely want
to hit you can do it next time
oh no I I don't think I do what I will
do though is we'll take a one-minute
break I feel I owe you both you know
what I can tell the ones I'm brothers
like water because now I finished your
water within about 10 seconds I was
going to give you some of you doctors
there's a we can go we can do it over
drinks all right throw it over we're
gonna take one minute we're gonna set up
some drinks maybe a pee break we'll see
what happens
give me two minutes max one to two
minutes stay right there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right the idea revolution now with
booze all right first off guys it's a
truly it's a joy and an honor to to do
these with you and be friends with you
guys and everything this is amazing
for the record Eric and I are on the
whiskey and Brett is on the rum you know
do what you may with that information
all right here we go
super chat looking forward to round two
all right there you go that wasn't
question do you think the uncanny valley
could be a perception issue writ large
as opposed to just a robot slash CGI
fish as opposed a robot CGI facial tears
Oh
more specifically is there a point where
people start perceiving shortfall falls
from the ideal so acutely that progress
goes unnoticed I think you both saw the
question sort of yeah whoever whoever is
asking that is definitely on to
something yeah okay very good
this is interesting and I think I've
sort of said this to you once before
privately Brett as a lifelong
progressive aren't you partially
responsible for what happened at
Evergreen is this just karma no Dave I'm
totally responsible this is a thing
everybody assumes this but the fact is
I've been fighting post-modernism since
1992
I never wavered I thought I armed my
students with the proper tools to see
right through this stuff so you might be
able to hold me responsible for allowing
this to go on elsewhere in the system
without recognizing the danger but you
certainly can't hold me responsible for
participating in it because I didn't I
actually spoke up from the beginning you
know some some time will do you with
Peterson here and we'll talk about how
progressivism and post-modernism let me
just also say that Brett has been
fighting this throughout and I've been
saying that from I've been seeing it
from afar there is zero responsibility
this is not a new position this is an
old position and Brett was probably you
know early in my in my life is telling
me you have to watch out for this area
in fact I failed a class in 1992 for
standing up to post-modernism with a
biological perspective right then I
fully accept your answer well this one
we're gonna have to kick to another
but Eric can you please tell us more
about your insightful four-quadrant
model and the type of individuals who
fit within each group well first off you
could catch that on this show and you
can catch it you also discuss it with
Sam and you did a little bit with Rogen
if I'm not mistaken I don't remember
that but the knife media just oh they
just brought a huge pieces thread a huge
piece on it and they gave four or five
worked examples and then they said for
homework apply it to ayaan Hirsi Ali
James dam or Peter Thiel so I think
they're running with it yeah I would
just add it is hard to get the first
time but like many complex ideas running
yourself through it a few times so you
get it is the key and this one is so
important to be able to unspin the fake
news that it's really even if it takes
you three times through its well happy
Newman Jordan Peterson interaction is
the thing that to be honest is making it
make much more sense to many more people
I was just gonna say then the Knife
media piece that they did on it because
they use so many graphics and everything
but I think really really did help I was
just listening to Brett's second
appearance on Rogen's show and was
wondering if he thinks that the
intellectual dark web is new game B and
if so how does he think we might best
test the theories and ideas that the
intellectual dark web puts out the
intellectual dark web is definitely a
game B to the Academy's game a and the
thing is the way to think of it is that
game B I mean game B was actually never
intended to be the name of anything it
was a placeholder for a superior
alternative to a feeble system a system
that has become strong but feeble at
delivering the goods and that's what
civilization looks like so yes an
endeavor to to think more clearly than
the system can think itself is a type of
game B and there are many others I think
this one's actually for me have you ever
had a prospective guest attempt to
dictate what could and couldn't be
discussed in advance of a show if so did
you agree to their terms and still have
the monitor politely tell them to devour
a bag of dicks patreon love coming soon
never a hundred percent never I always
say to my guests that there are no rules
and that we don't edit for content one
time I had a professor say that there
was a specific period of history he
didn't want to talk about cuz he wasn't
an expert in it uh
Eric seemed to say that 2008 burst the
deregulation narrative how do you answer
economists that say we caused a credit
fueled and regulatory directed boom bust
that one's gonna be hard to do quick
yeah it's hard to do quick you know I
think that to some extent as an emergent
phenomena we found stories and
narratives to compress volatility
temporarily only to have it roar back I
think that the problem is is that the
the lack of a credible source of growth
does make Liars of all of us when we are
in the institution's we particular
individuals lied more than others and
that helped to fuel that maybe some
people thought that self-regulation
could work but that was fraught with
principal-agent problems and if you
don't bail out the system
maybe you teach the system a lesson but
it's too costly given how everything is
there and I'm not doing yeah you can't
really do that quick I had one that I
loved and then the screen moves oh I
love this as children what was the
biggest situation you both teamed up
against to accomplish well that I don't
know how to answer that question maybe
Eric will have something but I will say
because of the different ways that Eric
and I responded to our scholastic
dysfunction
Eric was five years ahead of me in
school he's three and a half years older
but he was five years ahead in school so
in some ways there was less overlap than
there might have been in situations that
otherwise would have emerged you have
anything nothing that I can talk about
I'm a former state director of Wolfpack
I stepped down for reasons similar to
you Dave should I publish my experiences
publish your experiences let's see
Theresa May just announced she will
present new measures to tackle quote
abuse speech to protect quote female DME
and LGBT people what are your thoughts I
mean I'm pretty sure we're probably
always well I may be in a different
position than the rest of you my belief
is is that I'm pretty absolute on free
speech when it comes to ideas mm-hmm and
when it comes to privacy
or abuse my feelings are slightly
different we have a fourth amendment as
well as a first amendment and what can
be done online you know it's fairly
terrifying we have to balance things
that are actually precursors to violence
or you know really very dangerous forms
of speech but in general for ideas there
should be very little if any protection
and Europe has a different history with
aid speech than we do in part because of
the Second World War but I think that we
should not abandon our own experiment
with not having hate speech as a
protected category for the world of
ideas we do have to worry about speech
that that represents some you know clear
and present danger or turns over prior I
don't want somebody being able to say
that they can turn over all of your
privacy because it's free speech and
protected so III break a little bit with
our community and then I'm not a free
speech absolutist
and when we say free speech at the u.s.
we have lots of adjustments to free
speech yeah although I think most of the
people relatively around us for the
fourth amendment okay but that's a whole
other but we may have to reinterpret
what that means in an era where anybody
can publish anything and then the whole
world can see it could Brett be the
biology answer to Jordan's liberal arts
program money permitting PS Eric I mean
absolutely no offense but I think your
facial cysts may harm your message Brett
your apathy to university reminds me of
me what was the question yeah could you
be the biology answer to Jordan's
liberal arts program you mean could I
play though could you play the role of
the biologist in that endeavor well of
course I mean you know that the thing
the thing about biology though is it is
such a gigantic field just by virtue of
the number of organisms the number of
systems within those organisms what
happens when you put the organisms
together that there's no such thing
really as a biologist you can't be
expert in at all but if you wanted to
pick a place to go to see the landscape
clearly at all those different scales
evolution would be the
it's the unifying principle behind all
the other kinds of biology so yes this
is really good okay if I just get one
second on that one yeah there are always
a small number of people who comment on
my facial moles for example and I just
wanted to say something actually
directly into the camera in particular
for all the young women out there who
are concerned that their appearances are
used to limit them and to denigrate them
and my feeling is this is none of
anybody's business if you want to make
these comments feel free but most
importantly this is no bar this is no
problem and if this is what you're
fixated on on this show you're really
telling us much more about your own
level of intellectual engagement and you
know particularly young women stand up
for yourselves and don't let anybody
give you any guff you're fine the way
you are and nobody really cares Thanks
well I appreciate you taking that moment
and as you can see I'm reading these on
the Flyers all right your complaints
about the journal gatekeepers for
biology or very often arguments used by
the dissident scientists in climate
change do you think that is
fundamentally different or the same
effect could be happening there there's
a lot there but it's a good question
well it's about time this came up let me
put it this way I'm a believer in
anthropogenic climate change but I am
very concerned about what I don't know
what I have seen in biology tells me
that the incentive structures inside of
publishing and inside of career-making
in academia cause corruption I can
guarantee you there is corruption inside
of climate science and I do not know
enough climate science to be able to
tell you which stuff you can trust and
which stuff you can't I believe that the
consensus that we are causing this the
stuff I can check you know we have a
very simple chemical model of what the
alterations to the atmosphere that come
from co2 and methane would cause in
terms of heat trapping so that we know
that this is true chemically at a level
that doesn't require fancy models right
and we know that we're changing the
composition of the atmosphere with
respect to the
those compounds so the globe ought to be
warming is it warming it appears to be
is there liable to be a bias in favor of
papers that flatter people's
pre-existing expectations there will be
and so this is part of the predicament
is there's too much resting on our
ability to detect what's going on to
allow a corruption of the system to
pollute what we know but I would say if
we go back to what we were talking about
earlier about the fact the failure
across civilization is really a bunch of
symptoms of a small number of problems
my feeling is we should go great guns
after the climate issue even if it
turned out not to be true the things
that you would have to do to fix it are
necessary to the solution making that we
would have to do anyway and so my
feeling is so in other words even if
it's if it's exaggerated it's still
doing solar doing green all of these
these are good things right but let me
say I know a lot of smart people who
have skepticism at one level or another
about the climate stuff a lot of us are
nervous about what we don't know in that
space what I would say is we should go
after it because if you're wrong about
the climate change being
anthropogenically driven and dangerous
and you address the problem you've still
solved something important and if
there's just no there's no question that
that is the the place where the smart
money would go even if you have a
tremendous amount of uncertainty about
the models and the data I'll just throw
in a bonus question there on this one
but it's interesting because I know how
thoughtful you aren't careful with your
words but when it comes to this one and
even the way you said you've been
waiting to answer this yeah there's
something about this topic that brings
out something so insane in people right
that literally for all the controversial
people that I've had on my show the most
hate I ever got was because of this book
right here the moral case for fossil
fuels right with Alex Epstein and he
wasn't even denying climate change but
there's something about that that even
for people in your respect because he'll
right so it's phrased as surely you
don't disagree with the consensus of 98%
of scientists and the answer is anything
that sounds like that is going to
immediate
trigger a counter-reaction which is why
are you a approaching that topic and
that a very tortured in a very strange
fashion right and the problem is very
similar I think I pointed out - maybe we
jumped the gun
tying HIV to AIDS and because the gun
was jumped a lot of people said there's
not enough evidence and they hung on
with that too long so just like with the
noonas memo that you know I can see
you're playing politics does that mean I
shouldn't take the topic seriously I can
see that the IPCC may be strong arming
people or creating an artificial level
of consensus does that mean that the
underlying problem isn't a problem this
is one of these typical problems that
the indicia is one of coercion and
people who are anti coercion in general
will go the opposite way often be led
into error so I would also point out
there's something that in particular
caught my attention which is a a story
that unfolded in the llamó Peninsula in
Russia and Siberia where some actually
ironically enough some petroleum workers
were flying in a helicopter and noticed
a geological phenomenon that they
couldn't identify and it turned out to
be a couple of giant craters and for a
while we didn't know what they were and
the hypothesis was that these were
actually explosive releases of methane
due to novel warming and that hypothesis
survived a hypothesis test which is they
went down into these craters and
measured methane levels which were
through the roof so what people do not
understand about the climate is that the
parts that are certain are very
frightening the amount of frozen methane
in the Arctic is absolutely gigantic and
we are playing with suddenly releasing a
huge amount of methane that will take
the question of climate completely out
of human control now do I know for sure
that there's nothing in that story that
is going to come back to haunt me I
don't because I'm not a climate
scientist but as somebody who's capable
of checking various parts of the story
the fact that something is going on that
is actually creating novel geology in
fact we don't even have a word
for what these craters are the closest
word we have is Pingo Pingo is a is a
phenomenon where frozen water causes the
soil to lift up out of a hole right this
is not a Pingo right we don't have a
word for what this is an explosive
release of methane so what I would say
is the fact that you've got very simple
chemistry that predicts we've got a
problem and then you've got novel
geology saying something new is going on
that's enough to scare me into saying
emergency let's deal with it even if the
complex models are not secure and I
would say stop strong-arming quite so
obviously quite so much and you will
find that more of the skeptics will sign
on and I am worried about this and I do
think it's very real but I also think
that anybody can see the heavy hand of
coercion and trying to create the
consensus and it's creating one of these
backlashes and unfortunately you get
very smart contrarians like Freeman
Dyson who are gonna you know be the
challengers and so fundamentally I think
it's a very dangerous situation where
you know where you want to get to and
you decide to cut the corner and that
creates the back I mean I had a little
of that myself I was just like why would
I want to deal with this topic again no
I mean yes again anything you try to
tell me I can't talk about that I create
some number of people to say I gotta
talk about that because that's just
stronger honest on a more personal note
I hope you know the answer to this one
so what people don't know about you I
think is that you're an incredible
musician and every time I'm with you you
grab something it doesn't even have to
do with music and you make music out of
music what's that crazy wacky thing you
have in your house
what's that thing the clone yeah that
thing and your people need to Google
this thing because you were put but the
question is what make and model piano do
you play and you're a great pianist -
yes the way I said that you are just
come on stop being humble for one second
hawai up right I had a birthday party in
Sean Lennon who you know said you mind
if I bring an instrument I said no
problem
he brought an upright piano and he never
petty left it yeah so wait I have to say
though yeah the story about Harry giving
Eric guitar and telling him to tune it
but you don't have to play it that
results in Eric having picked
how many instruments can you play
something on I mean more or less it's
all theory it's none of it as musical
ability it's all theory and then the
idea is that each one is just a slightly
different interface into this
abstraction and so it looks like okay
you play any instruments but that's not
at all what's going on it's just right
but I really underlying secret and any
instrument affords the same operation I
mean I'm in there you're playing the
ukulele you're playing the piano you're
playing that thing you're banging drums
so the the the word intersection is no
fun anymore intersection between math
language and Eric has also picked up
many different languages not that not
fluently but the point is enough to get
by yeah you know Turkish Russian I mean
the point is there's something
interesting going on with Eric and the
ability to abstract these very
particular things so that he can jump
from one to the adjacent wouldn't you
agree too if you agree to [ __ ]
yourself so that you will never achieve
mastery you can pick up a very large
core very very quickly by rearranging
through this trick of sort of 8020 you
know do 20% of the work get 80% of the
benefit and almost no education is
structured this way but if you actually
wanted to educate people like this you
could suddenly have an entire population
of presumably learning disabled kids who
could suddenly do so much more than they
ever imagined because it's you know
everybody who plays the guitar they that
they have a lot of positive
reinforcement if you play the piano
you're doing scales and learning to read
music in two different staffs for
forever before you get to anything
interesting and so if you make the world
look much more like the guitar where
three or four chords unlocks you know
85% of the music that you want for want
to play you can do that with anything
you can do it with language you can do
it with mathematics if you do with
biology we just don't teach that way I
believe Tom Lehrer is still alive not
that mr. Lehrer would want to admit it
all right what are your thoughts let's
forget that one Star Wars or Star Trek I
think I know I better know your answer
at this point I hate to say it but I'm
more Star Trek than Star Wars I know
this is where I
get tossed out of the intellectual dark
web over some hours I knew that was
gonna be it yeah let's see Thank You
Eric as a gay man my answer to shallow
idiots your comments say far more about
you than they do about anything about me
boom thanks alright let's see scientific
objectivity is impossible for whenever
challenged with what they believe to be
true to engage in the necessary neuronal
or wiring inevitably goes against
self-preservation ah not a question but
no that's well if I understood if I said
yeah I think what the person is saying
is that in order to do scientific
thinking well you actually have to have
a kind of it'll reverse relationship
with your own well-being up and in fact
who could turn said something I don't
think he's got it quite right but he
said you have to be bipolar because you
have to be able to be enthusiastic about
a new idea and then to go after it
viciously in order to see if it's true
and there is something to this that a
willingness to follow the truth wherever
it leads
is inconsistent with an obligation to
protect yourself now and still it moves
I mean that sums it up and Allah knows
right now 100 year prediction closer to
1984 or brave new world that's a good
one well I guess it depends what which
way all this goes right if we get to a
hundred years it can't be either one of
them if it's if we get to a hundred
years it will be and I don't mean to
claim it it will be some game B that
succeeded from somewhere in the world
that taught us what to do next and if we
don't do that what will be left here
will be unrecognizable that would be my
guess I know you were both traveling
today so I don't know that you can
address this specifically but any
thoughts about the current stock market
plunge there's I barely saw the the
underlying I mean my concern is is that
the level of volatility and the
clean path up can't possibly be
sustained in a world that's this nutty
and so it's the mystery is not the claim
that the world goes crazy it's that the
world goes sane and that's so
spontaneously the climb up that seems a
little bit nutty to me so I would say by
while it's low unless it's gonna go low
he is an expert I'll tell you oh I like
this question tip tips for someone with
learning disorders
yours go ahead
how severe your learning disorders if
they're severe enough you need to come
up with an entirely different toolkit or
you won't make it those tools exist
because every subject is much easier
than the people who wish to make money
teaching it would have you know so for
every single subject that can be
systematized there is a systematization
that allows you to get 80% of the power
with probably five or ten percent of the
effort and so the key question is you
have to prove that you have the
superpower to rearrange the subject to
disintermediate the people who get paid
for teaching it which will always push
you towards mastery which is the
question of getting the last two or
three percent out of the system and so
the good news is is that you can
rearrange any subject to learn most of
it very very quickly the bad news is is
that it will feel terrible because you
will be told yet you were doing the
wrong thing and dooming yourself to a
life of mediocrity as the jack of many
trades master of none but in fact the
problem is that the jack of one trade is
the connector of none good luck
oMG this is easily the most invigorating
session yet I feel compelled to rejoice
in the new dawn of reason alright I'll
take it
what is the most compelling for both you
guys what is the most compelling
argument you've heard for a creator and
the most compelling evidence against it
and under two-bit the most compelling
argument because I can just go yeah you
go alright fundamentally that there has
to be a boundary condition or there has
to be no boundary condition if there's
no boundary condition that results in
the creation of everything and
presumably it's cyclic enclosed and
somehow catapulted into reality out of
necessity because that which is not
precluded must exist it's not a very
terrific argument but it's a question of
logo Maki and the redefinition of the
word creator was the best argument
against it and it seems to me that
everybody who tries to speak about
creators with specificity runs into the
problem of why your version and not
somebody else's version so the only
version that it survives as an abstract
version and the abstract version
fundamentally is largely denuded of the
reasons that we talked about creators to
begin with okay I now have my ass I was
going to give you a pass
no no I want this one now the best
argument for a creator is the regular
Pentagon on the pole of Saturn which
looks like a rendering error in a
simulation that didn't invest heavily on
the paths of Saturn that was a septagon
is this where you guys come to blows but
but in any case that's the best argument
I'd never heard anybody make it but I
looked at it and thought could it be the
best argument against a creator is the
fact that there are 360 lien stars in
the visible universe and that that
number is so gargantuan that no creator
who gave a damn about us could possibly
have created that much other stuff it
just doesn't make sense to the creator
night sky as the point is in what we see
in the night sky is like you can
visually our local neighborhood it's not
even outside the galaxy for the most
part right so the point is we're looking
at a few thousand stars that are our
nearest neighbors and the universe goes
on for 360 liyan stars which is I mean I
promise you if you look into how big
this number is it will make your mind
hurt the number of the
you would have to name more than one
star per second for every second the
universe has existed to even have named
them all so what's the point of all are
you saying it's more than billions and
billions just yeah that's all right Carl
Sagan I've listened to Brett speak about
evolution as hardware and software
hardware evolved slowly and software can
evolve more quickly when talking about
software are the changes at the level of
DNA or mimetic oh the software well
first of all should be cautious mimetic
I would argue is cultural
so memes are passed on between members
of the same species our software is
largely pneumatically taken on but it is
also partially and not an insubstantial
part generated on the fly as we take on
the lessons that our parents and other
other members of our species give us we
then deploy them in the world and
discover how they're not nuanced and we
discover everything from how to operate
our limbs to how to understand people's
facial expressions so the point is
software is largely mimetic it is
partially learned in a non mimetic way
it is not genetic the analogy is that
the genes program the hardware and the
hardware just like your home computer is
nothing without a software package that
allows it to be functional all right
we've got about three minutes left is
monitoring your position on the Pareto
distribution a wide way of understanding
when to switch games if success is a
cinnamon synonym for production for
example are you in the right job or
neighborhood or field of study etc ooh I
have to be honest with you the Pareto
distribution but it's not phrased in an
easy way okay search costs are always
high and part of the problem for some
entrepreneur would be to try to figure
out how do you really match people with
the appropriate mate the appropriate
geographical locale the appropriate
training program nobody's ever solved
that problem convincingly most of us
stumble into our lives don't think that
there's any way of optimizing this yet
if you think that you have a way of
fundamentally figuring out how to match
people up with what they're supposed to
be doing
there's a multi-billion dollar business
for you to found good luck let's end on
this one because I think for so much my
audience that focuses more on the
political side of things I think it'll
be a nice way of getting us there would
we have better luck trying to grow the
Libertarian Party or convincing people
to eliminate the two-party system and
run on individual merits and ideas and
instead for me it's just like well the
party itself actually is ripe for
hijacking they have no stars anymore and
at least they're on the ballot so I like
some idea around that um I wouldn't do
that frankly I actually wouldn't Bank on
any of the existing parties whether
they're third parties that you think
might be ascendant or whether the two
major parties I would say we have
discovered that the founding fathers
built a system that had many of the
right ideas but it had some flaws in it
some of which it's clear why they didn't
spot them but that in order to get to a
new realm we have to go one of two
routes one route involves some sort of a
major revision like a constitutional
convention and I must say this is the
last thing I want to see I think it
would be a disaster right at this moment
would be terrible it would be odd it
would be a circus right it would it
would end very badly yeah
the other way to do it is a kind of a
game B approach and to look at the
structures of the system and to
understand that you can alter it through
a mechanism that is non coercive and
that spreads because it makes sense for
people to adopt it so nobody legislated
that we would all have smartphones they
didn't need to because we adopted them
to get the benefits of the smartphone
what you want to do is recognize that
the opportunity to fix civilization the
one that makes sense
involves creating a what used to be
called a glide path or what I would call
the foothill of an adaptive peak that
causes people to adopt because it makes
sense for them to do it and as it
unfolds it deploys something that takes
a good first guess at where we're going
and then increases in its effectiveness
as it
assesses how well it did relative to
values that frankly all reasonable
people share I would say first take a
look at Arnold clings concept of
progressives libertarians and
conservatives according to him the thing
that matters most to progressives is
oppression what matters most
libertarians is coercion and that
matters most of conservatives is
throwing over the lessons hard-won from
tradition it would be insane not to be
worried simultaneously about oppression
coercion and loss of tradition so
fundamentally to be libertarian is to
have an under versified portfolio
because you're so offended by the
excesses of the other two wings so it's
the answer cannot be libertarianism it
cannot be conservativism it cannot be
progressivism it has to involve tensions
and dialectics between all of these
things and if you're going to think
about trying to do something
fundamentally new now is not the time to
have a constitutional convention because
the epistemic contamination and
pollution is so pervasive that we don't
have the clarity that we would have from
something like British oppression but
fundamentally try to listen to somebody
else try to hear the other side of the
story and listen to those three axes and
develop in yourself to become a full
human being a reverence for the
willingness to fight oppression the
willingness to fight coercion and the
need to uphold the lessons that were so
hard one that we're handed to you by
your ancestors in their parting gift to
you as we say in the Jewish tradition
the door of a door from generation to
generation and somehow if you're in any
one of those three camps you're sort of
missing the point
that's a beautiful answer my friend this
get this has been a pleasure for me I'm
gonna treat you guys to some steak how
does that sound
XO guys like steak right well really
well one more time really it's been a
pleasure and
I'm yeah I am I am learning as I'm doing
this all right thank you guys for
watching we've got a regular show coming
up on Wednesday and yeah we'll take keep
throwing in the questions and I have a
feeling they'll be back and we'll see
what we can do all right thanks
everybody